THANKS THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
READING OF THE MATERIAL BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE ALL START AS A
SUB COMMITTEES I GET THIS RIGHT
HìNH ADVANCE. GOOD MORNING I
WOULD LIKE TO COME COME THE CAN
BE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
DUE TO THE STATE HOME ORDER WE
ARE PRACTICES SOCIAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THOUGHT THE CAPITOL BUILDING-
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATING HEARING-
IN PERSON WE'RE ALSO RECLINED
SB ONE FIFTH. PHYSICAL MATTER
AREN'T FOR THE- EIGHTEEN OF ALL
THE NUMBERS THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WOULD BE HERE IN THE
ROOM OR THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITES IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
MASSIVE TO PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
WE CAN HAVE A DIFFERENT WE HAVE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS IN OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES- TESTIFYING TODAY.
FOR THE PUBLIC IN A ROOM TODAY
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS YOU
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SOME GET MAINTAIN SIX
FEET OF DISTANCING. THOUGH ALSO
STRICT- DOUBLE DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN
THE ROOM. ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I'LL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. BUT ALSO AS THE PUBLIC
NOT TO TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN YOUR SEATS PLEASE BE
SURE TO SERVE THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED THE ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. FOR CALLING WITH WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH OUT
ANY OF THE WITNESS START START
THROUGHOUT WHICH ANY OF THE
WITNESSES CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS NOW REPET THIS A
COUPLE TIMES. 1-576-989-5787
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
WILL BE. TWO FOUR TWO SIX. TWO
THREE SEVEN TWO FOUR TWO SIX
TWO THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER I'D BE
ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATION THE
VEINS COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL
AS YOUR AS WELL AS YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU WERE IF YOUR
CALL PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AT
THE ALTAR THE BILL YOU'RE
BUYING IS ARE BEGINNING. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED. AB PLACE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE LIMóN ANY BACKGROUND
NOISES INCLUDES MEETING YOUR-
YOUR LICENSE BROADCAST OR YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTRACTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU HAVE IF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL. ARE YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE IN YOU
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL
YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PAUL.
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE. ARE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
SIXTY SEVEN THE REPEAT THAT.
916-319-2627 IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS COMMUNITY
CONNECTING. AND OUR STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO HELP YOU. I ALSO
WANT TO KNOW THAT IF YOUR EX
THAT WE'RE ACCEPTING A WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL AND THE
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT THESE METHODS TO
CONTINUE SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO FOR BEING
MY FLORA RESPECTABLE OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO JUST
WALKED IN WE STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE FOR ONLY THE PURPOSES
OF READING IN ADVANCE. OF THE
SAFETY GUIDELINES. ALTHOUGH WE
DON'T HAVE AN AUTHOR.
NOTICING
A QUORUM PRESENT- I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN AND MADAME. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
SANTIAGO HERE OBERNOLTE.
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. DAVID
CHIU. FLORA I WANNA GARCIA.
HOLDEN KAMLAGER. LOW PATTERSON.
PAXIL THE- RODRIGUEZ. WE HAVE A
POOR. THANK YOU ALSO MAKE THE
MAKE A COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS
MISTER FLOOR HAS BEEN APPOINTED
AS A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE-
FOR TODAY'S HEARING AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO- FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WILL BE REPLACING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. I'M I'M
PRESENTING SOUL BE WALKING AWAY
LEAVING- THE VICE CHAIR. TO
BEGIN WITH.
GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
ELEVEN THIRTY WHICH IS A
CRITICAL MEASURE TO HELP CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE BOTH DURING
AND AFTER THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC A LACK OF ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED INTERNET WAS AN
ISSUE IN OUR COMMUNITIES WELL
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC TO COLD.
ACOSTA SEEING EXAMPLES DIGITAL
DIVIDE IS PREVENTING
CALIFORNIANS EXCUSE ME FROM
ENGAGING IN CRITICAL DIGITAL
ACTIVITIES THE STUDENTS HAVING
TO GO TO STARBUCKS PARKING OT
TO GET THE WIFI CONNECTION DO
YOU DO TO THE TO DO THEIR
HOMEWORK OR OLDER CALIFORNIANS
WHO DO NOT HAVE FAST ENOUGH
INTERNET FOR TELEHEALTH
SERVICES WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
COULD FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE CONNECTED. AND AS FOR
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION WE MUST
DO BETTER THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE
A LACK OF LONG TERM INVESTMENT
IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY READY
BROADBAND TECHNOLOGIES IS A KEY
DRIVER OF THE STING TO BUY.
SPECIFICALLY BILL READ OF. THE
BILL REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND. TO BETTER ENABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO BE
BUILT IN UNSERVED AREAS. THIS
CHANGE IS CRITICAL- AND WILL BE
ENABLING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
I. S. P.'S INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS OF ALL SIZES. TO
APPLY FOR GRANTS AT THE SAME
TIME INVEST IN THIS TECHNOLOGY.
CURRENTLY THE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE BAND
SERVICES FUND ARE TIED DIRECTLY
TO LOW INTERNET SPEEDS MAKING
MOST INTERESTED ENTITIES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO DEPLOY. FASTER
SPEEDS IN ELIGIBLE FOR THE
GRANT FUNDS WE MUST LEVERAGE
AND MAKE SMART INVESTMENTS WITH
THE CURRENT PUBLIC DOLLARS FOR
OUR SEATS FUTURE. IT ALSO
ALLOWS THE PUBLIC UTILITIES.
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
FINANCE OPEN OUR HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. WHICH WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO BE ON PAR WITH
INTERNATIONAL NORMS I WOULD
LIKE TO CLARIFY AS WELL THE
ACCEPTED SENATE POLICY
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
ANY CONCERNS RELATED TO URBAN
OR SUBURBAN. BETTER UNDERSERVED
HAVING THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
GRANTS BUT UNSERVED RURAL
AREAS. RURAL AREAS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY INSTITUTE WILL STILL
HAVE PRIORITY TO ACCESS GRANTS
FROM THE FUND. AND IN ADDITION
I HAVE PROVIDED THIS COMMITTEE
OFF BUT MEANT. I ADDRESS SOME
REMAINING TECHNICAL. THE BILL
ONLY 59% OF RURAL HOMES BUT
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN HAVE
BROADBAND. AND LOS ANGELES ONE
QUARTER OF STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS AT HOME AT ALL. SB
ELEVEN THIRTY OUT OF THE
SENATE- OUT OF THE SENATE WITH
BY PER. CENT SUPPORT AS A
PRIORITY BILL OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS WELL. ASK I WAS JUST
RUSHING SO EXCUSE ME I'M LIKE A
BIRD NOW. THANK YOU THIS CALL
YOUR MEN'S FOR WITNESSES YES WE
HAVE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAVíA TELEPHONE IS FOR
NESTOR FAUCON YOUR LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL WITH THE ELECTRONIC.
TERMINATION TRACY REINER JUSTLY
TO ADVOCATE WITH REAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
ERNESTO ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES I'M HERE. BUT CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN TOWARD SIR OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU SIR HI BUT
YOU'RE NOT THE ARGO BY OPEN THE
OKAY IN THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE INTERNET THE FALCONE
AND NINE BE SENIOR LET'S SAY
FOR THE TRUCK FRONTIER
FOUNDATION- WE'RE LAW FIRM AND
HAS THE KID A SUBJECT AMOUNT OF
LEGAL AND ENGINEERING RESEARCH
INTO THE QUESTION I. GET EVERY.
TOWARD THREE. WE LIVE IN BEGIN
THAT AND PROCESS OF FIXING THE
PROBLEM THAT COVERED AT
HIGHLIGHTED WITH A TERM FOCUS
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM. FIBER
OPTIC IS A YOU AGREE IF FOR ANY
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY NETWORK BY
YOU DON'T YOU DO EVIL NOT HAVE
ADVANCED PUBLIC SAFETY RESPONSE
EQUIPMENT SUCH AS REAL ON OF.
AFTER FIVE G. NEXT WIFI OR OR
GIGABIT INTERNET WITHOUT FIBER
OPTICS BEING A CENTRAL CENTRAL.
OF THE INSTRUCTOR PLAN
EXTENDING FIBER IS AN
AFFORDABLE A PRODUCTION POLICY
INTO THE INSTITUTE FOR ALL
SUFFER LINE- NONPROFIT THAT
SPECIALIZES ON GOVERNMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS CAN BUILD YOU
TWELVE MILES OF A FOUR LANE
ROAD FIFTY MILES OF RIGHT FOR
DOZENS OF MILES. FIBER CHECK
THE CHANGES AT ELEVEN HAD
WITHIN THE METRICS THERE WERE A
REFLECTIVE OF ADVANCEMENT IN
BROADBAND THAT OCCURRED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS AT THAT THE
MINIMUM STANDARD TWENTY FIVE
MEGABITS PER SECOND DOWNLOAD
AND TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS PER
SECOND UPLOAD. BY THIS ONE SURE
ABOUT THE ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT CURRENTLY
INELIGIBLE FOR PARTICIPATION IN
THIS PROGRAM BUT LACKS HIGH
THREE AXIS WILL BE PART OF THE-LARGER INSTRUCTION PLAN. IT'S
CREEK THIS. THE ELDERLY
CRITICAL GIVEN THAT. SCALE AN
AGGREGATION OF THE MAN FOR AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE. THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO MAKE THESE
NETWORKS SELF SUFFICIENT
FINANCIALLY AND ABLE TO ATTRACT
ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF
INVESTMENT TO MATCH THE STATE
EFFORT. IT ALSO A SPECIFICALLY.
MARKET THAT A MODERN CABLE
BROADBAND SYSTEM I HAD
UPGRADED. BECAUSE THOSE SYSTEMS
WHICH OF ALL THE BEEN UPGRADED
WITH FIBER. OPERATE WELL BEYOND
THE TWENTY BY TWENTY FIVE
METRIC AND REACH AN ESTIMATED
8% OF AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS TODAY
PER THE CABLE INDUSTRY
TESTAMENT. IT ADOPTED THE
DIGITAL DEFINITION OF ON
SERVICE A HIGHLY HI PROPERTY
AREAS SPECIFICALLY TARGETING
LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS IN
PUBLIC HOUSING PROJECT BECAUSE
OF FEDERAL DATA INDICATE THAT
THOSE AIR BLACK ACCESS AS WELL
AS- NUMBER OF WORLD MARKETS.
ONE WHO BECAUSE FIBER PROTECTOR
HAS SUCH A POTENTIAL. THE
GENERAL CONSENSUS AMONGST
TACTIC TECHNOLOGIST- IS IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL USEFUL AND
GROWING IN A USEFULNESS FOR
THAT THE YEARS ONCE BILL. TO
PUT I THINK TAKES OFF BY
SUPPORT EARLY DAYS IN THE
INTERNET AND NINETEEN SEVENTY
WE STILL USE IT TODAY AND IT'S
STILL IN HIGH YOUTH IN HIGH
DEMAND TODAY. LASTLY IF ELEVEN
THIRTY ENSURE THAT STATE
FINANCE PROJECTS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO BE OPEN ACCESS TO
LIFT ALL BOATS INCLUDING- COULD
BE THE OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION. BECAUSE EVERYONE
BEAU PUBLIC AND. SHOULD BENEFIT
FROM THE BILL THE HIGH CAPACITY
FUTURE PROOF STRUCTURE. HE HAVE
A COMMENT SENATOR. FOR HER
EFFORT HERE ON SB THIRTY WE ARE
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS
LEGISLATION. AND WE WRITE
REQUEST YOUR AYE BILL IN THE
PORT WITH WORKING WITH ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
FALCONE. CENTER DO YOU HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL MAIN WITH THIS. YES
TRACEY RYAN THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH RC RC THE RULE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. I UNDERSTAND SHOULD
MISS- RYAN IS ON THE TELEPHONE
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN A LINE FOR
MISS RUN. MORNING ADDED TRADE
DEADLINE- BROKEN RECORD THE
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
THIRTY SEVEN MEMBER COUNTY. AT
THE FACT THAT BY THE PRIOR
WITNESS BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
PRACTICES SHOWN A LIGHT ON MANY
THE FINAL CRACKING CREVICES.
AND ONE OF THE- EARLY ON WITH
THE CONTINUE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
WORLD COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
LIVING WITH THE LACK OF I WILL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
SERVICES MANY CALIFORNIANS TAKE
FOR GRANTED FOR DECADES. AND
THAT'S A STATE RELIABLE SERVICE
AT THE BASELINE THIS DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE QUALITY OF OUR MOST
WORLD WRESTLING CURRENT. QUITE
FRANKLY DOOR. BEGINNING A
PANDEMIC. THE PRIME OF THE
SECOND HALF THE SCHOOL YEAR DO
YOU NEED NEED TO TRANSITION TO
THE BURNING THROUGH MOST
TEACHERS STUDENTS AND HELP.
ENOUGH THAT CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER
NECESSARY TECHNO AVAILABLE AND
AS A MATTER IT WAS JUST A
MATTER OF COURT INSURANCE IS
ACTIVE TO THE NEEDED THAT HI
MANY RURAL AREA OF WAS IN A
MUCH BIGGER PROVIDING HOT HOT
LAPTOP IS THAT THE FOR SERVICE
ALL NATIONS TO ISSUE AROUND THE
PARK. THEY'RE NOT LUCIEN HELP
MOST OF CALIFORNIA ALL THE
ACCESS TO BROADBAND SOMETHING
ARE COUNTY CONTINUE JUST. TO
ATTAIN. AT MAKES SPENT ON MY
NEEDED CHANGE TO THE- DANCER
BUT PROGRAM THAT WAS JUSTIFIED
OF FUNDING OF OUTDATED IN
UNRELIABLE. IN ROW AREAS TO THE
DEPLOYMENT OF TECHNOLOGY THE
WILL ASK ALLOW TRUTH. IN RURAL
IN HIGH AREAS OF THE. IT
REQUIRES FUTURE TECHNOLOGY
WHICH MEANS THE AREAS THE STATE
THAT CURRENTLY STRUCK WITH IN.
BROADBAND ACCESS TEL HELP.
PLATFORM FOR DISPLAY BURNING IN
TECHNOLOGY FOR TELECOMMUTING
NOW ABLE TO PARTICIPATE WITH
EQUAL FOOTING WITH THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA. IT ALSO MEANS THAT
THE STATE WILL NOT CONTINUE IN
PERPETUITY THE SUBSIDIZED WITH
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL NEED TO BE REPLACED
MOST LIKELY WITH MORE PUBLIC BY.
AT ELEVEN THIRTY WILL ALSO
ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
APPLY FOR FUNDING. OF GET BOTH
BROADBAND PROJECT. LOCAL BY THE
VERY PROVIDE FOR THE WELFARE
THEIR RESIDENT. ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE PEOPLE
ELIGIBILITY FOR BROADBAND IT'S
INVESTMENT IN THE GREAT THE
FINAL IN REGIONS THAT HAVE NOT
SEEN MUCH INVESTED BY LARGE
SERVICE PROVIDERS. AS WE IN THE-
MANY AROUND THE HAVE OPERATED
BY THEIR OWN NETWORK. WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE OFFICE
AT BIRTH ELEVEN THIRTY IN AGREE
THAT NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE
THESE IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE
CATHOLIC PROGRAMS AND FINALLY
BEGIN TO BRIDGE THAT DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THANK YOU WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK CLEAR I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU MISTER.
pOF YOUR MADE WITH THIS IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
WE'LL GO NOW TO THE PUBLIC FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITNESSES
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS BILL- FIRST
LET ME ASK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
PERSONAL SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
THE CHAMBER. ALL RIGHT CITY
SEEING NO ONE SEEKING
RECOGNITION WE WILL LOOK FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
IS THERE ANYONE WAITING TO
TESTIFY ON THIS BILL. HEARING
NONE WILL GO TO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WITNESSES ON THE
TELEPHONE MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE WAITING TO TESTIFY ON
THIS BILL. THERE ARE ARE FEW IN
Q. AND AS A REMINDER IN THE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. WILL GO FIRST TO THE LINE
OF LINE TWENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN OKAY LET ME
REMIND EVERYONE THAT OR JUST A
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
THE BILL PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAMELA
GIFTS REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. AND STRONG THE COURT
OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY THANK YOU.
OVER THE LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT TECHNICAL
DOLLARS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY SIX THREE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MAKING THINGS
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE WRITERS
GUILD OF AMERICA WEST IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS LISA CHAIR FROM
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
THE COLLEGE FOR ALL COALITION
WE'D LIKE TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT ELEVEN THIRTY THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH. LINE TWENTY ONE TO
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
SEVEN THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. APOLOGIZE COLOR ONLINE
THIRTY SEVEN FORTY ONE YOU.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES SIX SHOULD
MAKE NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF TURN WE HAVE A
SUPPORT AS AMENDED POSITION
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE-
THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY NINE TO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MANY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WAS HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY ONE THREE ONE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING CHAIR
NUMBERS SIR MY NAME'S KEVIN
CHARMER ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPANY TO FIVE SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN CALIFORNIA SUFFOCATION A
BLACK SO EDUCATED STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY ONE FOUR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU ANDREA
BALL ON BEHALF OF THE LONG
BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND DONT SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AGREE ON
BEHALF COMMONSENSE WE'RE PROUD
TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
MEASURE IN OUR PRODUCT ORDERS.
THANK YOU. LINE FORTY SIX FOUR
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. STATE FARM
PROPOSED BROADBAND CONSORTIUM
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT SO- SO IF YOU TAKE
DIRECTOR FOR A RP CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU OUR
LAST THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
POLITICS ARE LESS LEARNING CUES
LINE THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU TO
SEE IF THE LAWYER ON BEHALF OF
THE CANADIAN INSTITUTE WAS
TRYING TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FOR NO OTHER REASON YOU AT THE
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE CAROLINE
MCINTYRE FROM THE C. C. T. A.
ON THE TELEPHONE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THAT LINE. HELLO.
YES I MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THE TO CAROLINE
MCINTYRE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY- FIFTY TA IS IN
FACT OPPOSE TO BE ALIVE THIRTY
NUMBER OF REASONS FIRST LET ME
POINT OUT THAT WILL BE ELEVEN
THIRTY BACK IN FACT CHANGED THE
DEFINITION OF AN AND AREA TO
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE BY TWENTY
FIVE DOWN. HI I WOULD. THERE
ARE LIKE NO PROVIDER CAN IF OF
CALIFORNIA BETTER CURRENTLY
PROVIDING SERVICE AT THAT
SYMMETRICAL SPEED GLOBAL.
IRONICALLY THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE AND AN APPLE CAN'T TO
BUILD THEIR NETWORK TO AT
TWENTY FIVE AND THREE SPEED
WHICH IS ACTUALLY THE LAST MAN
HOW AND SERVE HAS BEEN DEFINED
THE BELL FELT. ONE FINANCE
LOOKING CAN BE THREE FUNDING IN
ORDER TO BUILD OUT A PROJECT
BUILDING TO THE TWENTY FIVE
THREE BUT NOT RENDER THAT AREA
INELIGIBLE. FOR FUNDING. BE
ACTOR DE. HAS DEFINED TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE I WILL ALSO NOTE
THAT SAYS AND THE AREA THOSE
ROLE. CAN PROTECT THAT HAPPENED.
WHICH CAN BE LIKELY CONTNUE TO
REMAIN AT THE END OF THE LINE-
AND LIKELY NOT HAVE THOSE
NETWORKS APPARATED.
INTERESTINGLY THE BILL WOULD
ALSO ALLOW FUNDING FOR OPEN
ACCESS NETWORK AS IDENTIFIED BY
THE AUTHOR BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WOULD PROHIBIT THE OPEN ACCESS
NETWORK FROM PROVIDING THEIR
OWN. MY CAN ACTIVITY THAT WOULD
REQUIRE AND NOW THEY'RE APPLE
CAN'T TO THEN HAVE TO ACT AT
THE A EXCEPT THAT THE OR- TO
INVEST THEIR OWN MONEY IN ORDER
TO CONNECT TO THAT OPEN ACCESS
ONLINE. THAT ALSO SEEMS TO BE A
VERY EFFICIENT WAY PROVIDE
NETWORK CONNECTIVITY AND USING
THE VERY SCARCE RESOURCES. THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE OF IT. MANY
THANK. JENNIFER SAID FROM A
MORE FULL PROCESS WHERE THE
MORE CAN A BY THE END OF CAN
ALSO BE FACT INTO THE BAY N
PARTICULAR THE FACT THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS IN THE
PROCESS AND NOT THE MAKING MANY
KAMALA BALL THE TO THE ARGOS
PROGRAM AND WE WOULD EXPECT A
LOT OF MONEY TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA TO ELIMINATE SOME OF
THE NEEDS THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE. WE ALSO HAVE- AT THE PPV
CURRENTLY HAS ABOUT FIFTY TWO
AB. FEEDING BEFORE IT THE TIME
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE LOOKING
TO BUILD OUT IN IT AND SERVE
THE AREA THAT ARE CURRENTLY
DEFINED THAT MANY THAT IS
AVAILABLE WE ESTIMATE TO BE
PAYING TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
AND- THREE HUNDRED BILLION. IS
THAT WHAT. AND THOSE
APPLICATION THAT WOULD MEAN
THAT THERE NO MONEY. TO FIND
THE NEW REALLY RUN CAL ADVANCED
SERVER FUND SO THE URGENCY OF
THE LEGISLATION- DOES DOES NOT
SEEN CAN PAN OUT GIVEN THAT
THERE IS NO NEW MONEY THAT ARE
BEING MADE AVAILABLE FOR THE
PROGRAM- I WOULD. THE BILL THAT.
ASIAN THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
PEACE TO AND RATE REGULATE OF
FOR BROADBAND THAT IS AT THE
PHYSICALLY CALL HIM BUT BY LAW
AND CERTAINLY NOT APPROPRIATE
FOR THIS BILL FOR THESE REASONS
WE OPPOSE AT ELEVEN THIRTY AM
WOULD AGAIN ENCOURAGE TO BE OFF
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TOO BAD THAT STOPPED
BILL THIS YEAR HAVING MORE
WHAT THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
WILL ACTUALLY BE ONE THE
CURRENT. AT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS HAVE BEEN SPENT
AND ONE THE FEDERAL MONEY HAS
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU
MS MCINTYRE I UNDERSTAND WE
ALSO HAVE CARE BUSH AND CHARTER
COMMUNICATIONS AS A MAN
POSITION WHERE WITH US
MODERATOR. PLEASE OPEN THAT
TELEPHONE LINE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRED MEMBER COMMITTEE
CARABUS FOR CHARTER
COMMUNICATIONS- MORE COMMONLY
KNOWN IN MANY COMMUNITIES THE
BACKGROUND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO TESTIFY.
OUR COMPANY IS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST BROADBAND
CABLE OPERATORS WITH MORE THAN
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
CUSTOMER RELATIONSHIP AND JUST
SHY OF NINE THOUSAND PLEASE
HEARING DATE. WE HAVE THE
DISTINCTION OF BEING THE ONLY
BROADBAND CABLE PROVIDER TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CATHOLIC
PROGRAM AS AN APPLICANT. IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BY PAUL OUR
FIRST FORAY WE WERE AWARDED
THREE SEPARATE GRANT FOR
PROJECT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THEN THE CURRENT. TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE GOAL WE FILED SIXTEEN
APPLICATION. FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE WANT THE AUTHOR THE BOND FOR
THERE REALLY TO THINK AND- WITH
THAT. HOWEVER WE MUST STILL
OPPOSE THE BILL IN FACT. IF YOU
ENACTED CELLS EFFECT WILL BE
LESS PARTICIPATION IN THE
CAPTIVE PROGRAM IN THE FUTURE-
CABLE OPERATOR OTHER NOT MORE.
BY THE RUSSIAN LEADER
PROGRAMMER OR AND THROUGH THE
PROCESS IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC IN A WAY THAT WILL
DISCOURAGE PARTICIPATION WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE. THAT WORK
WITH OUR COMPANY TO ADDRESS THE
MEDIA. NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS. I THINK THE CIVIC
ISSUES WITH THE BELL I WILL
BRIEFLY COVER A FEW. BIRTH THE
BILL REQUIREMENTS AROUND. THESE
ARE NOT. FEET IDENTIFY ANSWER.
AS AREAS WITHOUT A- SERVICE THE
THRESHOLD INTO FIVE POINT FIVE
AND NOT GIVE HIGHER SPEED.
ADDITIONALLY BILL. BASS PLAYING.
NOTING FUNDED PROJECT MUST HAVE
A GOAL OF ACHIEVING FUTURE
PROOF INFRASTRUCTURE. WHICH IS
DEFINED BY NOT ONLY BE
THRESHOLD BUT MINIMUM BLATANT
THE REQUIREMENT. BY CHARTER THE
NETWORK DELIVERING AND GIGABIT
MATCH THAN WITH THE NINE FORTY
OVER THIRTY FIVE MEGABYTES PER
SECOND OUR ENTIRE SERVICE
TERRITORY WOULD BE CONSIDERED
ON CERTAIN BECAUSE WE DO NOT
OPERATE SERVICE YOUR PACKAGE OF
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE. AND
LEAVE THE THRESHOLD REQUIRED BY
THE BILL ARE PROBLEMATIC AS
WELL. BACK IN THE WHOLE SO
ACTIVE THE BILL IS A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION FOR OUR COMPANY
AND POTENTIALLY EITHER. THE
BILL PROPOSES TO ALLOW THE UC
TO REQUIRE. OPEN PORTAL ACCESS
TO OUR SYSTEM. WHICH FOR OUR
COMPANY WE INCLUDE ARGUE SYSTEM
MANDATING BUT ACCESS OF OUR
CABLE NETWORK IS THAT ODDS WITH
CERTAINLY PREVENT. CONTINUING
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
CONGRESS SPECIFIED THE LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCE AND CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH CABLE SYSTEM
OPERATORS WOULD BE OBLIGATED TO
PROVIDE FACILITIES THE THIRD
PARTIES. CALIFORNIA HAS NOT AT
LIBERTY TO ESTABLISH NEW
SHARING OBLIGATION. I THINK
CABLE OPERATORS THAT WANT TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND RURAL AREAS
AND USE THE CAST THE PROGRAM
THE BILL THAT OUR NETWORK IN
AREAS THAT ARE OTHERWISE
UNECONOMIC. USER THE PROVISION
FOR THE TEAR AYE AND PERHAPS
OTHER PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROGRAM WARNING THE GOALS AS
BUILDING BROADBAND CENSORED
AREA. WE CONTINUE TO WANT TO
HAVE A ROLE IN BREAKING MADE
BRINGING BROADBAND TO RURAL.
AREAS WELL WE AGREE WITH THE
SPONSOR ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
SCHOOL AND MY SIGNIFICANTLY
AMENDED THIS BILL IS NOT THE
BEST WAY TO GET THERE. FORTY
REASONS AND OTHERS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE SB ELEVEN
THIRTY IF HOUSING COMMITTEE
TODAY AND INSTEAD AND ISSUED A
ROGUE STAKEHOLDER WITH THE CAN
BE CONDUCTED IN A MORE
PURPOSEFUL DELIBERATE. FASHION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
BUSH OTHER CONCLUDE THE OP.
TESTIMONY WILL GO NOW TO
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. AND PUBLIC COMMENT
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. GO AHEAD. WE GET THE
MICROPHONE TURN ON UP IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE. MISTER MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS CRESSMAN KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
COUNTY AND SHARE THE CONCERNS
OUTLINED BY C. C. T. A. N.
CHARTER THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL GO
TO OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS IS THERE ANYONE
WAITING AND AN RTS WAITING TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
FROM. SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE LINE-
OPERATOR PLEASE GO THROUGH THE
LINES OF PEOPLE QUEUED UP TO
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION. YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR MINOR IN
THE PRESS ONE ZERO TO CUBA.
WE'LL START WITH LINE FORTY
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEAT SO LOVE ON BEHALF
OF FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS-
WE'RE OPPOSED AN ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE MAIN TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I AM FIFTY THREE
FIVE BRING YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO EVERYONE POWER THE STATE
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE SUPPORT
HAD SOME TROUBLE CONNECTING HIS
GALEN YOUNG ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS AGAIN IN
SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU WILL PUT
YOU DOWN IN SUPPORT. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING- THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS A LOT
OF BANDS AND REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION SERVING RURAL
CALIFORNIA AN- MISSION THANK
YOU. LINE FORTY THREE FOUR
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
PAM LIMITS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. AT THIS TIME
OKAY WELL THAT CONCLUDES OUR
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR Q. NA AND- I
GUESS ALL LEAD OFF WITH A
COUPLE QUESTIONS SENATOR. I
WONDER IF YOU COULD SEE SOME OF
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE-OPPOSITION REFLECTING THE
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
AS WE ALL KNOW THE CASF IS
FUNDED BY A SURCHARGE FROM
INTEREST EIGHT PHONE AND VOIP
SERVICES. ALL RIGHT NOW STATE
STATUTE AUTHORIZES TO RETURN
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS YEAH AND-
WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY THAT THAT
IS CURRENTLY OVER SCRIBE SO IN
IF WE GREATLY EXPAND THE SCOPE
OF THIS PROGRAM WHERE'S THE
FUNDING TO FOR THOSE GRANTS
GOING TO COME FROM. YES MISTER
TURN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION THE FIRST THING I WILL
JUST NOTE IS IT ASSUMES THAT
EVERY PROJECT BE APPROVED AND
SO- I HOPE THAT EVERY PROJECT
AT THE APPROVED BUT USUALLY NOT
EVERY PROJECT AS A FOR PROOF.
I'M SO YES IT OVER THE COME OFF
OF THE WORK FROM IT FIRST THAT
AND IN SIXTY FIVE PREVIOUS
THERE'S STILL TWO MORE YEARS
COLLECT WORDS OF SIXTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR- THE
BUSINESS CHILI AN ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO IN THAT
COULD BE GOOD IN THE FIGHT.
THERE QUESTIONS AND I'M BOTH IT
WITH CAUGHT AND IN MY HOUSE
ABOUT A MORE OPPORTUNITY NOT
JUST STANDING ON BUT
DECISIONAL- DISCUSSIONS WITH
VARIOUS- STAKEHOLDERS ON ON HOW
WE CAN CONTINUE FUND- DIGITAL
POLLUTION ALL OUTSIDE OF THE-
THIS ONE BUT THE IS GOING TO
PICK A WE'RE GONNA HAVE FOR
SOMETIME TO COME SO DO YOU. THE
CHARGE SHOULD BE OR THE NO
SOURCES MEASURE POINT UP TO SEE
A OF. I THINK WE KNOW THEN
WEREN'T THE DISCUSSIONS I KNOW
IT'S- I GATHER. THE BILL THAT
DOES EXTEND THE FEE WELL SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT BOTH OF OUR
BILLS TO SEE HOW THEY CAN COME.
EACH OTHER AND OUT ACTIVELY
WORKED TOGETHER THAT. THANK YOU
BY THE CONCERNED BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT- IF THE
EXISTING PROGRAM ALREADY.
OVERSUBSCRIBED THAT THERE'S NO
WAY THAT WE CAN SET THIS GOAL
FOR OURSELVES WITHOUT THE
MASSIVE. SOURCE OF REVENUE. AND
YOU KNOW THE AYE AYE THAT'S A
DISCUSSION AND WE NEED TO HAVE
AT THE SAME TIME TO DISCUSS THE
MERITS. OF CHANGING OUR GOALS
YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO PAY
FOR THOSE. SO AT THAT THAT SO
THAT'S A CONCERT AND I HAVE. I
ALSO WONDER IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS IT ANOTHER CONCERN THAT
WE HEARD IN OPPOSITION. WHICH
IT IS THE TECHNICAL. FIREMAN'S
THAT ARE WRITTEN THIS BILL SO
YOU HAVE. ACQUIRED ONE OF
TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS PER SECOND
SYMMETRIC OPAL UPSTREAM AND
DOWNSTREAM BANDWIDTH. NOW OF
COURSE MOST CONSUMERS. UTILIZED
DOWNSTREAM MUCH MORE THAN
UPSTREAM IN FACT IT'S OVER 90%
WHICH IS WHY A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGIES ARE ASYMMETRIC.
BECAUSE THEY PRIORITIZE
DOWNSTREAM DOWN WITH UPSTREAM
THAT WITH. A WHY HAVE YOU
CHOSEN. A SYMMETRIC STANDARD
FOR THIS DEFINITION. WELL WE
ACTUALLY TOOK AMENDMENTS AND WE
ARE DOWN TO TWENTY FIVE THREE
WHICH IS ACTUALLY THE FEDERAL-
STANDARD. AND SO- WE'RE TWENTY.
THREE WITH GOAL OF TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE AND AS WE KNOW NOW.
KIDS WITH FIVE YOU KNOW THERE'S
FIVE OF US IN THE HOUSE ALL IN
AS SOON. THE THOUGHT OF A
DOWNSTREAM THREE OR ONE IS
ACTUALLY EVEN OUTDATED. YOU
NEED YOU KNOW I THINK- WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE FEDERAL FCC-
WEBSITE. THE ACTUALLY VIED BUT
NO ONE HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED
WHICH IS WHAT WE PUT IN HERE AS
A GOAL AND- IN ADDITION TO THE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
IN THIS DAY AND AGE IN AN OPEN
ENVIRONMENT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE I'VE SEEN IN DOWNSTREAM
SO. TELL YOUR TAKE A MOMENT TO
CHAIR OF AN ISSUE THERE ARE
ONLY FIVE THREE YES WELL
THEY'RE NOT REFLECTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND I DIDN'T
SEE THEM IN THE BILL SO WHEN
AND WHERE THOSE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN THOSE WERE TAKEN AT-
SENATE ENERGY COMMITTEE. IN
OKAY WELL IT'S THAT'S I WILL RE
REVIEW THE BILL BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THE TEXT OF THE BILL SAID
SO I WILL LOOK INTO THAT SOME
MORE COULDN'T WE TALK A BIT
ABOUT LATENCY BECAUSE THAT'S
ANOTHER THING THAT I HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT SO YOU IN THE
DEATH AND DEFINITION OF AN
UNDERSERVED AREA YOU'VE GOT A
DEFINITE THE DEFINITION
INCLUDES LATENCY. TO BECOME
SERVE LATENCY HAS TO BE
SUFFICIENTLY LOW TO ALLOW REAL
TIME INTERACTIVE APPLICATIONS.
CAN EXPLAIN A BIT ABOUT WHAT
THAT MEANS TO YOU BECAUSE- IT
IT HAS. A VERY AMBIGUOUS
MEETING TO ME I MEAN IT'S IT
DEPENDS ON WHAT KIND OF.
INTERACTIVE APPLICATION YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A FOR PLAYING
POKER. THAT'S IT REQUIRES VERY-
VERY HIGHLY CAN SEE IS
SUFFICIENT- IF WERE VIDEO
CONFERENCING- A MODERATE AMOUNT
OF LATENCY A SUFFICIENT AND A
FOR PLAYING A VIDEO GAME LIKE
FOR NOT ONLINE YOU NEED VERY
LOW LATENCY SO- SO CAN CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT. WHY THAT WHICH IS
IN THERE AND WHY IT'S NOT MORE
SPECIFIC. THE LOOSELY AND ALSO-
REACH OUT TO ERNESTO AS OF WELL
IF HE HAS ADDITIONAL INPUT BUT-
AS I MENTIONED OF IN ADDITION
TO THE BILL MANY. KIDS HAVE TO
BE AN INTERACTIVE. GUILLEMETS
WE HAVE NO CHOICE AND GENTLY
DISTANCE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
NO MY CHILD WAS JUST ON A
MINECRAFT CODING CLASS. IN
YOUR- NEED HIGHER THE BILL.
RIGHT AS WE AS WE HAVEN'T. I
AND SO THAT IS IN THE REAR IS
THAT WE NEED TO ADD THESE
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND WE ALL CAN
CONTINUE INVESTING PUBLIC
DOLLARS IN SLOW SPEEDS THESE
ARE PUBLIC DOLLARS REPAIR FUNDS
TAXPAYER DOLLARS BEING
UTILIZING NEED TO BE INVESTED
IN THIS FUTURE PROOF
TECHNOLOGY. WITH THESE
TECHNICAL CHANGES BUT- ERNESTO
IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL INPUT
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THAT AS WELL.
CERTAINLY SENATOR THANK YOU-
NOT SENATOR DID THE EXPLAIN
KIND OF THE LEAGUE AND SEE HOW
THAT WORKS RIGHT NOW WITH WITH
THESE NETWORKS- THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION
DOES A FAIRLY HOLISTIC ANALYSIS
ALL THE DIFFERENT TACK NEVER
TAKE TECHNOLOGIES AND IN THE
FUTURE PROOFING. I
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THAT TWENTY
AVERAGING TWENTY MILLISECONDS
OR LESS IS ESSENTIALLY KIND OF
THE INDUSTRY STANDARD WHAT LOW
LATENCY IS- IT MET BY A CABLE
NETWORK THAT ARE HAVE
IDENTIFIED WERE BUILT WITH THEM
AND IT'S MEANT BY FIVE THE HOME
NETWORKS EVEN IN IN IN VERY
DIFFICULT SEVERAL MARKETS. I IT
THIS STANDARD THAT- SPACEX IS
SHOOTING FOR AS PART OF THEIR
DEPLOYMENT OF LITTLE LITTLE
EARTH ORBIT- BROADBAND
NETWORKS. LEAN INTENSELY THE-
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT MAY TAKE
THE DATA THE MOVE FROM COME
FROM POINT TO POINT. FIVE VAN.
YOU COME. FROM WORKS OKAY. IT
FROM THE WIRE OR THE OF CAN
YOUR WITH. YOU HIGHER OR THAT
LIKE LOT OF ROLE RIGHT ARE
DEPEND ON NOW. STREAMING
HIGHWAY TO BECAUSE TAKES A VERY
LONG TIME THE INFORMATION
REACHED THE SO BEFOREEVENTUALLY MAKE IT BACK DOWN TO
EARTH TO CONNECT WEAPON THAT.
OR ON. YOUR COPPER WIRE
NETWORKS YUR DSL NETWORKS
WHICH- A LOT OF THE FRICTION IT
IN THE WIRE MR COCHRAN IF I
COULD ASK SINCE YOU'RE AN
EXPERT AND YOU BROUGHT UP LOWER
ORBIT SATELLITES. I UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THAT TECHNOLOGY HAS A
GOAL OF GETTING LEADING LATENCY
BELOW TWENTY MILLISECONDS SO
WOULDN'T THAT QUALIFY. UNDER
THE STANDARD. IT WOULD. IN
TERMS OF THE- QUESTION OF- SAID
THE NUMBERS BUT THE THING WITH
LOW OR SATELLITE AND KIND OF
THE LIMIT THERE IS. IT CAPACITY
INCREASING SERVICES SO IF.
PROVING BOB REQUIREMENT BUT THE
TV NEEDS LOOK INTO. LAST PART
OF IT AFTER THE PROOF WILL OF
INFRASTRUCTURE RAMPS UP
SPENDING- BECAUSE AS FAR AS I
UNDERSTAND THE BASICS AND KIND
OF THE OTHER LOW EARTH ORBIT
SATELLITE PLANS DON'T REALLY
RELY ON GOVERNMENT MONEY TO
BUILD IT OUT AND IF THERE'S
SOME REASONS FOR THAT NOW
EXPLAIN THAT- IF YOU WISH. BY
ALTERING THEIR POTENTIAL YOU
YOU'VE ANSWERED MY QUESTION BOB
BUT IT'S JUST OKAY I DON'T
PEND THE COMMITTEES TIME ON A
TECHNICAL DISCUSSION HERE BUT-
I HAVE A CONCERN THAT THOSE
TECHNICAL SPECIFICATIONS MIGHT
NOT MIGHT NEED TO BE REWORKED.
AND IN PARTICULAR I MEAN AT THE
ARE. YOU KNOW ME I'M A
TECHNOLOGY BACKGROUND- I OWN A
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY I'M
CERTAINLY VERY INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
BROUGHT. APPROVED AN INTERNET I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WERE VERY
FAR. ABOUT WAY WE GO IT. IN SO
MY FIRST CONCERN IS I RAISES
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE AN ATTACK
ATTACHED A FUNDING SOURCE TO
THIS. AND THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
ALREADY OVERSUBSCRIBED. BUT MY
SECOND CONCERN IS THAT WE ARE.
ARE PUTTING OUR THUMB ON THE
SCALES AND- WRITING THE
TECHNICAL SPECIFICATIONS TO
FAVOR ONLY ONE DELIVERY
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS FIBER. AND
WE HAVE OTHER DELIVERY
TECHNOLOGIES THAT MIGHT BE.
EVEN MORE APPROPRIATE FOR
SERVING CURRENTLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES LIKE WHAT LOWER
WITHOUT RIVER ORBIT SATELLITES
I MEAN THAT THAT DOESN'T
REQUIRE A LOT OF INFRASTRUCTURE
ONCE YOU PUT THOSE SATELLITES
IN ORBIT THAT COULD BE A VERY
APPROPRIATE INFRASTRUCTURE.
YEAH AND I JUST DON'T THINK
IT'S FAIR. TO JUDGE AND SAY THE
FIBERS THE ONLY THING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO. AWARD GRANTS
FOR- SO WE- BUT- CHERISH
REGULATE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THAT THAT THE FUTURE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVEN'T DICTATED FIBER. JUST IS
FUTURE PROOF TECHNOLOGY WOULD
COULD WHICH COULD BE A HYBRID.
WHICH IS MANY AT THE WHICH MANY
OF THE CAMP MANY SAY THAT THE
HALF. AND SO UP WITH THOSE
SPECIFIC. AS AS MENTIONED
TWENTY FIVE THREE AND THE LATE.
YOU CAN SEE ISSUE AS WELL SO.
THERE ARE. NO KNOWLEDGE TO YOUR
POINT OKAY AND I WERE VERY
CLEAR. THE BILL WOULD YOU ARE
MOVING OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
FOR ME FIVE. PERCENT DOWN TO
AND THREE MAKE A PER SE.
UPSTREAM CRAP. OKAY OTHER
FURTHER. I MISS STARS ORBIT. I
SHARE YOUR CONCERN I WITH
CALIFORNIANS DISTANCE LEARNING-
DURING COVE IN NINETEEN AS WELL
AS A NUMBER OF PARENTS WHO ARE
COLOR WORKING ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE BROADBAND ACCESS TO
EVERYONE IS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE- I DO I HAVE A
CONCERN OF USING THE WORD
FUTURE PROOFING BECAUSE IF WE
LOOK AT THE TECHNOLOGY TWENTY
YEARS AGO. AND WHAT IT'S GOING
TO BE IN TWENTY YEARS SO MAYBE
THERE'S A WAY THAT WE CAN GET
NEUTRAL AND THE LANGUAGE AROUND
WHAT KIND OF TECHNOLOGY THERE
IS- BECAUSE I THINK THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO CHANGE SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE. THAT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE NOT
DISINCENTIVE EYES FROM SERVING
RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES SO THE FIRST THING.
THE SECOND THING IS I WANT TO
REITERATE TWENTY FIVE THREE NOT
TWENTY FIVE FIVE SEVEN THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. COULD YOU
TOUCH ON THIS BECAUSE I KNOW
ERNESTO WHO WAS ONE OF YOUR
WITNESSES IT WAS A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO HEAR HIM SO MAYBE
YOU CAN REPEAT- ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE IS THE
MISUSE OF IT WHEN YOU CHECK RE
CHANGE THE STANDARD TO TWENTY
FIVE THREE. THE MISUSE THAT
COULD HAPPEN I THINK MAYBE THIS
IS THE OF THE CONCERN OF SOME
OF THE COMMITTEE. THE MISUSE
FOR MIDDLE MILE PROJECTS FOR
SOME OF THINGS WHERE YOU'RE
JUST EXPANDING ALREADY
PROFITABLE AREAS. AND NOT
REALLY GETTING AT THE LACK OF
PROVISION OF BROADBAND ACCESS
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES. AND THE
TRULY UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. SO COULD
YOU ADDRESS HOW YOUR BILL IS
TURNING THAT HOW YOU PROVIDING
THE MIST DOSE. OF THIS FILE.
AND THEN ALSO. CAN YOU MAYBE
GIVE US ALSO THE HISTORY OF THE
FUNDING ISSUE BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN GOING ON AND YOU
SAID YOU WERE STILL WORKING ON
IT AND SO I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY ALSO TO TALK
ABOUT HOW THAT'S EVOLVED- AND
MAYBE WHAT WE CAN EXPECT AS A
COMMITTEE IF THIS BILL GOES OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY SURE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- IN TERMS OF
THE WHOLE UNSERVED THERE'S NO
SHIFT IN PRIOR FROM PREVIOUS.
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT A SURVEY OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
COMPLETELY OFF THE GRID
UNSERVED AND SO THAT WILL
REMAIN A PRIORITY HERE- IN THIS
BILL- OF COURSE WE'VE EXPANDED
WHAT UNSERVED ACTUALLY- LOOKS
LIKE MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S A
HIGHER THRESHOLD FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN VERY HIGH POVERTY AREAS
TO BE ACCESS FUNDS UP OR COULD
HAVE BEEN A HOLD OF THAT YOU
ACCESS THESE FUNDS AT NO THERE
WERE NO WERE NUMBER. TEN FOR SO
WE'RE EXPENSE TO GET FOLKS ON
COMPLETELY BE WE START BUILDING
AGAIN WITH SPEEDS OF TWENTY
FIVE THREE AT LEAST IN THIS
THAT IS YOUR. HOW ARE. HOW HI
JIM THAT'S GONNA WORK IN REAL
LIFE IF BILL PUT INTO LAW I HAD
A THAT HOW DO THEY PRAYER THEY
SAY. ALL UP WITH IN THE WORLD.
NO BROADBAND CAN BE THEY GET A
PROOF AND ALL YES IS THERE ARE
NONE THEN WE CAN GO TO THE
INCOME. CONSTRAINED UNDER
COMMUNITIES AT ONLY ABOUT. THAT
YEAH THAT IS CORRECT OKAY
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN A PRIORITY
WITH YOU SEE RIGHT NOW THIS
FIFTY FOUR APPLICATIONS I THINK
ALMOST ALL OF THEM. OR ABOUT
90% OF THEM ARE ARE RURAL
COMMUNITIES OF THAT ARE
UNSERVED BUT AGAIN- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE OF UP APPLICATION HICK
UPS THEY MAY NOT MAKE IT
THERE'S A LOT OF VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT THE PC
MAY NOT APPROVE ALL ALL. YOU
KNOW FIFTY FOUR OF THEM- BUT I
HOPE THEY DO- THEIR OWN ROLE
UNSERVED AREAS- AND THEN THE
SECOND TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
FUNDING OF COURSE- THIS IS A-
BUT THE TRAJECTORY FROM. THESE
A ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA BILL
WHO BASICALLY LOOK LOOK AT
THESE FUNDS A THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER A
FOUR YEAR PERIOD. WE'RE JUST-
PROGRAMMATIC THE CHANGING YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT. IS BUT- WHAT WE
WANT TO DO OF COURSE IS HAVE
FULL DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD
WITH- LIMóN KURT IF YOU TWO
ARE VERY MUCH INVEST THIS IS
THE DISK. AND OF YOU WHO WOULD
TO BE INVESTED IS AS WELL WE'D
LOVE TO HAVE THAT TO TALK ABOUT
NOT JUST THE CALIFORNIA
SERVICES FUND. AS WE KNOW THAT
UP. YOU KNOW THE- SIR ONE IS
ONE OPTION BUT THERE'S ALSO
OTHER GRANTS AVAILABLE THERE'S
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS AT THE
FCC IS JUST NOW- ALLOWING FOR
RURAL COMMUNITIES TO ENGAGE IN.
AS WELL AS- DIFF DIFFERENT
DISCUSSIONS AND HOW WE CAN
LEVERAGE BOTH FEDERAL. UP A
FEDERAL DOLLARS AND HAVE AN
ONGOING DISCUSSION ABOUT- OTHER
MEASURES TO CONTINUE FUNDING
THESE PRIORITIES. SO THERE'S A
LOT OF DISCUSSION HAPPENING ON
THAT I KNOW THE SENSE OF
URGENCY IN THIS BUT WE HAVE TO
START MAKING THESE. CHANGES NOW
IN MY OPINION. IF WE ADDRESS MY
QUESTION ABOUT ANSWER ATHLETIC
QUESTIONS AT ONE TIME IS. LIKE
PARKS THEM OUT- WHAT ABOUT THE
MIDDLE MILE PROJECTS HOW ARE
YOU PROVIDING ABUSE OF. THIS
FINE FOR PROJECTS OR MAYBE. A
YOU KNOW AN UNSCRUPULOUS ACTOR
WHEN YOU WANT TO GET MIDDLE
MILE PROJECTS OR WHATEVER AND
SO IT DOESN'T REALLY GO TO. YOU
KNOW THEY SAY IT QUALIFIES. BUT
IT DOESN'T GO TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE WE WANT SO. HOW ARE
HOW'S YOUR BILL PREVENTING THE
MISUSE. WELL WE DON'T
SPECIFICALLY CALL OUT THE
MISUSE BUT I THINK WHAT- YOU
KNOW AND I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S
A RAMP IT AS MAYBE SOME
BELIEVE. I THINK MIDDLE MILE
PROJECTS IN MY OPINION HAVE
BEEN- VERY GOOD PROJECTS LIKE
SAN LEANDRO HAS A GREAT MIDDLE
MILE PROJECT ANCHORED TO A
SCHOOL DISTRICT. THEY'RE ABLE
TO PROVIDE- FUTURE PROOF
TECHNOLOGY TO ABOUT LIKE A TWO
OR THREE MILE RADIUS FOR THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY AT A VERY LOW
COST. AND SO MIDDLE MILE-
COUPLED WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO NOW APPLY
FOR THESE- THESE FUNDS I THINK
IS A REALLY GOOD. OPPORTUNITY
MORE ON THE POSITIVE SIDE THAN.
THE NEGATIVE BUT I UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERN AND WE CAN LOOK
THAT UP TO THE PC. RIGHT MISTER
LOW AND THEN MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE I SORT
OF FEEL LIKE I'M BACK AT HOME
BECAUSE WE'RE SORT OF PEEKING
OUT ON THIS TECHNICAL ISSUES
RELATED TO TECHNOLOGY BUT IT'S
GOOD TO KNOW THAT THE SENATOR
YOU ALSO HAVE A TECH BACKGROUND
SO UNDERSTANDING YOU AWARE THIS
IS COMING FROM I THINK ALSO
AHEAD. OF COMMENTING PREVIOUSLY
AND SHARE THE CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT TO SHIFTING THE FOCUS
FROM UNDERSERVED AND RURAL A TO
THAT OF THE- OTHER COMMUNITIES
THAT MIGHT HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE LIKE IN
MY COMMUNITY AND SILICON VALLEY
AND SO THE CONCERNED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE MAINTAIN THAT
INTENT TO SERVE. OF THE ROLE
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO THAT OF
THE SERVICE FUND AND THAT
BEING- OF THE MAIN FOCUS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT OF THE
FOCUS ON CONSTRUCTION OF VERSES
THAT A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
TO REALLY PROVIDE THAT HAVE
THIS AND PERHAPS YOU CAN.
PROVIDE SOME INSIGHT ON THAT.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT POINT AS WELL-
TO ENSURE THAT EOPLE DON'T
JUST HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT THAT THAT THEN THEY'RE
ACTUALLY CONNECTED- SO. I KNOW
THE ADMINISTRATION- TOOK ABOUT
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WIFI'S AND HOT
SPOTS AND WILL YOU KNOW THE
FUND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT-
ESPECIALLY IN THESE. AREAS THAT
ARE HARD HIT SO I THINK- THAT'S
WHAT EXACTLY WHY WE WANTED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THIS PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT- THEY HAD ACCESS TO
THIS BUT ALSO COULD DO THAT
WORK- WITH US AND THROUGH THIS
FUN SO. ABSOLUTELY AND DISTANCE
LEARNING AND DIGITAL CURRICULUM
AND ALL THAT SO ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. OUR COLLEAGUE FROM THE
MONA YES SENATORS I SPOKE
EARLIER TODAY- REGARDING THE
FUNDING MECHANISM THAT'S MY
BIGGEST ISSUE I'M STRUGGLING
WITH HIS BILL THAT IF SOME OF
THESE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
DON'T SEEM TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN RELY ON FOR FUTURE YEARS
WHAT WOULD THE IMPACT BE AND
COMMITTEES LIKE MINE AND OTHERS
BECAUSE I WOULD HATE FOR OUR
FUTURE- REVENUE SOURCES BE
TAKEN AWAY FROM. KERN IS LIKE
MINE I KNOW WE KIND OF DON'T
WANT SOME REPETITIVE WE TALKED
A READING SOME OTHER COLLEAGUES
AT SOME ISSUES REGARDING THE
FUNNY PART BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
I WOULD REALLY WANT TO COME TO
GRIPS ON MY COMMITTEE IF THIS
BILL MOVES FOR ON THAT IT WOULD
IMPACT COMMUNITY LIKE MYSELF
OF. GOD FORBID HAPPENS AT THE
OTHERS NO UNDER ADDITIONAL
FUNDING RESOURCES THAT CONTINUE
THIS PROGRAM. IN FUTURE YEARS.
ABSOLUTELY AND DULY NOTED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- I YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS AND AS MENTIONED
BEFORE THE FUNDING- THERE AGAIN
IS STILL TWO YEARS AGAIN THAT'S
A DROP IN THE BUCKET A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS WE
KNOW WILL GO. IN THE BLINK OF
AN EYE THERE'S ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THIS HOUSE TO
ENSURE THAT WE LOOK AT
EXTENDING THE FUN AND OR
ADDITIONAL- FUNDING
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SERVICES FUND. AGAIN
PULLING DOWN LEVERAGING DOLLARS
THERE'S A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
ROLE- FUND A GRANT OPPORTUNITY.
THROUGH THE FCC THAT COULD BE
LEVERAGED TO THIS FUN
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS PROGRAM
ACTUALLY. I THINK IT. A DIRECT.
BUT WE'RE STILL. DISCUSSING THE
FUNDING AND I HEAR YOU AGAIN
LOUD AND CLEAR. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. HEARING AND SEEING ON
I WOULD BRING IT BACK TO THE
AUTHOR OF ANY CLOSE THE
STATEMENTS THANK CHAIRMAN THAT
THE I'M SORRY BECAUSE CAROLINE
MCINTYRE I HAVE A CLARIFYING
QUESTION. IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
AUTHOR ACCEPTED AN AMENDMENT
THEM I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT. DID SHE AMEND THE BILL TO
CHANGE THE OTHER THIRD
DEFINITION TO TWENTY FIVE DOWN
AND WE ASK. I WILL GIVE THE
MINISTER BACK FOR SECOND- I
WALKED IN A LITTLE BIT LATE SO
ON APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT THIS
BILL STILL NEEDS A MOTION AND A
SECONDORDER GONNA REQUEST OF
THE COMMITTEE AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS ANY
AMENDMENTS. ARE TAKEN ON THE
FLOOR THAT I AGREE TO. THANK
YOU. N. I'M GONNA BRING ABOUT
THE- BACK TO ME QUESTIONS- THIS
KAMLAGER. I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE
I APOLOGIZE WE HAVE A FIRST.
AND WE HAVE A SECOND. REPORTER
PUT- YES MISTER BECAUSE ROGER
PORTER FOR CLARIFICATION IN THE
AUTHOR'S TESTIMONY SHE SAID
THAT THE BILL SHE WAS MOVING
OUT OF COMMITTEE. SPECIFIED A
MINIMUM OF TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS
PER SECOND DOWNSTREAM BANDWIDTH
AND THREE MEGABITS PER SECOND
UPSTREAM BANDWIDTH AND I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE MOTION
THAT WERE MAKING JUST TO SEND
IT OUT OF COMMITTEE- COMPLIES
WITH HER WISHES IN THAT RESPECT.
I'M GONNA TAKE THE MOTION TO BE
WHAT IS WRITTEN IN THE BILL.
OKAY WELL THEN WE HAVE A
CONFLICT BECAUSE THE AUTHORS
TESTIFIED THE TWENTY FIVE THREE
IS WHAT'S IN THE BILL AND MY
READING OF THE BILL SAYS A
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE IS
WHICH IN THE BILL THAT'S MISTER
IF I MAY. MAKE A CLARIFYING
STATEMENT BECAUSE I DID
MISSPEAK SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
OF CLARIFYING THAT. YES I'M OAK
BUT- IF WITH THE AUTHOR LEVEES-
SAY THAT THE BUT WHAT WHAT I'M
GONNA WHAT WE'RE GONNA
ENTERTAIN IS WHAT'S IN THE BILL
IF THAT'S OKAY WITH THE AUTHOR
IS THAT ACCURATE YES ATTACK
THANK YOU. SO OKAY. A SO THE
MOTION I TAKE TO BE WHAT'S IN
THE IN THE BILL BUT IN A IN AN
ABUNDANCE OF. IN AN ABUNDANCE
OF CAUTION AND I'LL JUST ASK
FOR NEW MOTION TO VOTE WHAT TO
VOTE FOR THE BILL. WELL FIRST.
I WE HAVE A SECOND AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS ON THE BILL
THAT IS PER CURRENTLY IN PRINT
SO. I'M STILL LOOKING FOR MY
SECTORS I APOLOGIZE. MR SECKER
AND COMMITTEE CONTROLLED. YEAH
RUSSELL SO I WOULD LIKE A
CLOSING COMMENTS. YES I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT IT IS
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE WE HAD
BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS AND IT WAS
MY APOLOGY I THOUGHT WE HAD-
TAKEN THE AMENDMENT AND SENATE
ENERGY FOR TWENTY FIVE THREE IT
IS TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE WITH
THE GOAL OF A HUNDRED A HUNDRED
BUT WE ARE AGAIN STILL ACTIVELY
DISCUSSING. WHAT I WILL SAY
THOUGH IS- I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR- ENGAGING IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS I KNOW THIS
IS NOT VERY EASY ESPECIALLY.
WITH THIS PANDEMIC BUT I AM A
FULLY ENGAGED AND I HOPE YOU.
CAN SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS HERE SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE PRODUCTS ARE MOTION IS TO
PASS THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO ALL
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NO
BOERNER HORVATH. THE MOBILE
RIVER HI BONTA. DAVID CHIU.
FLORA LARA NINE EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN. HOLDEN OUR HOME LONGER.
KAMLAGER HUH LOW. LOW HI
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NO SIX
OVER. THIRTY SEVEN NOT VOTING
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ ARE. BUT
BUILT ON CALL.
COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND JUST ASKING FOR
INDULGENCE WIDE WHY THE- WHY
THE OTHER AUTHOR WALKS DOWN
OKAY SO I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE
WAIT. I AM PRESENTING IN THAT
AUTHORS COMMITTEE AS WELL SO ON
RUNNING BACK TO DOUBLE CHECK
THAT. AND BACK TO MISTER THAT'S
OKAY.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE SO
IN. I THINK WE'RE READY TO GO.
WITH WITH THE OTHERS PLEASE
APPROACH. ONE AT A TIME ALL
THIS TO KEEP THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND WE'RE GONNA
HEAR SP FOUR THIRTY ONE.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE-
BACK UP ELECTRICAL SUPPLY. YOU
WANT TO OPEN UP THOSE TO VIEW
AND THEN WE'LL GO ON TO- MAKES
FOR WITNESSES DOZEN WITNESSES
IN THE MAIN OPPOSITION THANK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND- IT IS A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOU IN AND THEN WITH THE
CHAIR AND ANOTHER COMMITTEE ALL
MORNING AND- APPRECIATE. HIS
WORK FIRST AND FOREMOST
INSINCERE ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
ISSUE ALONG. WITH A VERY
CAPABLE STAFF TEAM. WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE ALSO WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT- SOME NUMBERS TO SAY
THANK YOU TO SINGER GLAZER. FOR
IS PARTNERSHIP ON THIS BILL AS
A JOINT AUTHORED. THAT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE THE
BILL BEFORE US TODAY SUPPORTED
BY BOTH. REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. IN IT'S THE
CULMINATION OF OVER A YEAR OF
WORK WITH COUNTLESS MEETINGS
AND PHONE CALLS- WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. DURING LAST
YEAR'S POWER OUTAGE TO BUCKLE
AT ITS PEAK NEARLY TWO MILLION
TWO MILLION IN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. HAVE THEIR LAND LINE
CELLPHONE INDOOR CABLE PHONE
SERVICE INTERRUPTED. AT ONE
EXTREME EXAMPLE WAS IN MARIN
COUNTY WHO HAD 57% OF ITS TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY. CELL PHONE TWO.
ADAM SERVICE AT. ONE DURING A
POWER RIGHT OFF THEN. PHONE AS
WE ALL KNOW OUR OUR LIFELINE
IT'S HOW WE KEEP INTO WITH THE
OF THE AND HOW WE RECEIVE
EMERGENCY ALERTS IT'S TIME
CALIFORNIA STEPS UP AND DOES
THE RIGHT THING IN MANDATE CELL
TOWERS HAVE BACKUP POWER THIS
BILL ISN'T ABOUT CHECKING YOUR
FACEBOOK STATUS IT TRULY IS
ABOUT LIFE OR DEATH. IN
CURRENTLY ONE CELL TOWERS AND
COMMUNICATE TELECOMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE GO DOWN
AFFECTING NINE ONE ONE SERVICE
OR THE ABILITY FOR EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS IT'S AN EMERGENCY
ALERTS CITIZENS HAVE NO BACK UP
TO TURN TO SB FOUR THIRTY ONE
WOULD REQUIRE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES IN THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY TO
DEVELOP AN IMPORTANT BACK UP
RULES FOR TELECOMMUNICATION
SERVICE LOCATED IN TIER TWO OR
TIER THREE HI FIRE THREAT ZONES
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THOSE
STANDARDS VERY QUICKLY WOULD
INCLUDE. REALLY SHOULD PROVIDE
A MINIMUM PROPERTY LINE FOR
BACK POWER FOR A- NET. NO LESS
IN SEVEN TWO HOUR WE ORIGINALLY
WERE LOOKING AT EVERY CELL
PHONE TOWER THAT'S NO LONGER
THE CASE WORKING WITH INDUSTRY
IT SIMPLY CREATING A MINIMUM
STANDARD OF SERVICE DURING
THESE OUTAGES. WIRELINE
PROVIDERS SHALL PROVIDE MINIMUM
SERVICE OF AT LEAST SEVENTY TWO
HOURS OF BACKUP POWER FOR
CRITICAL FACILITIES
SPECIFICALLY OUTLINED IN THE
BILL NOW THIS THESE FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN. GREATLY NARROWED
WE'RE LOOKING NOW JUST AT
HOSPITALS AND POLICE STATIONS
AND FIRE STATION. FOR THE
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS RURAL
HEALTH CLINICS IN UTILITIES
SUCH AS WATER SEWER AND
ELECTRIC AT THIS BILL WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THE CPC TO ESTABLISH A
PROCESS WHERE PROVIDERS CAN
IDENTIFY FACILITIES. NAT CANNOT
COMPLY WITH REQUIREMENTS AND
AUTHORIZED TO PC WAIVER DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION ESSENTIALLY THIS
DOES. IS IF A TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANY SAYS THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO MEET YOUR
REQUIREMENTS THEY'RE ABLE
SENATE A WAIVER ESSENTIALLY IN
THAT. TO THE PUBLIC YOU TO
PLEASE COME. IN FOR MONTHS-
BOTH IT AND I'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AND I KNOW
THAT A GOOD FOR OF US WE ARE
SHOULD OF. OF THEIR ENGAGEMENT
AS WELL THE INDUSTRY IN OUR
OFFICES HAVE GONE BACK AND
FORTH ON. TO NORTH TO ADD SOME
WORKABLE AND IF THE AND I THINK
THAT WE- MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS ON THE NAME IS TO
PROVIDE. INDUSTRY MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO ACHIEVE THEIR
REQUIREMENTS THROUGH THIS BILL
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THAT
ENHANCES THE PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN
THEY COME THEY COME TO DEPEND.
ON THE WORK FORMS WE SHOULD TO
THE OF BATTERY. REQUEST FOR A
FROM. YOUR ENGAGEMENT WE'VE.
ALSO CLARIFIED THAT THE BACKUP.
AT POWER ONLY NEED FOR BY BASS
LEVEL SERVICE HERE'S WHAT THIS
BASIC LEVEL SERVICE HERIS HOUSE
TO FIND TO MAKE PHONE CALLS
SUCH AS NINE ONE ONE. RECEIVING
EMERGENCY ALERTS FROM YOUR
LOCAL EMERGENCY PROVIDER YOUR-
YASSER YOUR SHERIFF'S OFFICE IN
BASIC WEB BROWSING SO WHEN YOU
GET AN EMERGENCY ALERT. TO YOUR
CELLPHONE MOST- YES OFFICE IS
NOW SEND YOU A LINK BUT YOU
HAVE TO CLICK ON TO BE A TO
LOOK AT AN EVACUATION MAP.
YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
USE THAT WEB BROWSING FOR THE
BASIC FUNCTION OF CLICKING ON
THAT TAX WE'VE ALSO REQUIRE THE
CPUC CREATIVE PROCESS FOR
INDUSTRY TO IDENTIFY ISSUES
WITH THE BACK OF REQUIREMENTS.
IN GET REALLY FOR DELAY IF IT'S
NEEDED AND WHILE INDUSTRY NOTES
THAT THEY HAVE ISSUES WITH THE
WAIVER PORTION THE BILL IT WAS
ACTED WITH THE OF THE- AND
FIFTH. SO MUCH THE- AS A WAY TO
CREATE UNCERTAINTY FOR OUR
INDUSTRY CAN COME FOR WITH THE
GENERATED. AND GET RELIEF THAT
SAID YOUR ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS FOR
THE SPECIFIC ISSUE. JUST ABOUT
TO WRAP UP AND TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR GLAZER BUT AGAIN. THIS
BILL BEFORE EXPENSE OF WORK AND
COUNTLESS MEETINGS WITH A FORTY
CONTAINER WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY AND STAKEHOLDERS.
PORTLY LOOKS TO BE IN
FOURTEENTH. FOUR THIRTY ONE
SUPPORTED CALIFORNIA SHE SYSTEM.
PROFESSIONAL FIRE STATE SHE-
LEAVING CALIFORNIA. I WOULD NOW
LIKE RETURN MY CAR. CENTER
COREY HOME HERE TODAY HE TO BE
YOU CAN SHERIFF. AS WELL AS MY
MCGRAW HE'S A CHIEF WITH THE
CAN. COMMUNITIES DISTRICT FROM
TURNED OVER TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM AROUND. THANK YOU CENTER
MCGUIRE THE CENTER GLAZER. FOR
SURE SIR. THANK YOU OF A SECURE
NUMBERS IN MY GOOD COLLEAGUE.
ENTER MCGUIRE IS THAT A GOOD
JOB OF OUTLINED MANY OF THE
ISSUES IN THE BILL AND MY-
STRONG APPRECIATION TO HIM FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP HE'S BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR. MUCH
LONGER THAN I HAVE AND-
APPRECIATE ALL THAT HE HAS DONE
TO. PROTECT HIS CONSTITUENTS
AND OUR STATE. AND I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT. YOUR CHAIR- WE SPENT
I THINK A HALF DOZEN MEETINGS
AND PHONE CALLS OVER THE LAST-
SIX MONTHS ON THIS ISSUE DEEP
ENGAGEMENT- HONEST CONVERSATION
ABOUT TRYING TO FIND
ACCOMMODATION AND COMPROMISED.
AND I THINK THAT THE BILL
BEFORE YOU REPRESENTS THAT.
LISTEN THAT PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF NOBODY WANTS THEM.
THEY'RE A NEW PHENOMENON IN OUR
WORLD. IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
THE UTILITIES- LIKE TO DO AND
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT SOMETHING
THAT THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMMUNITY- FEELS LIKE IT'S
THEIR FAULT- THESE ARE NOT
THINGS THAT- THAT WERE
EXPECTED. JUST A FEW YEARS AGO
BUT THERE BEFORE US AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF- WHEN THEY
HAPPEN OURS ARE SERIOUS- NOT
SMALL THINGS IT'S BIG THINGS
LIFE. SAVING THINGS AND- WE
WORKED ON THIS BILL I MEAN THEY
THE ASK THE ESSENTIAL QUESTION
IS THIS. THINK ABOUT YOUR MOM
YOUR DAD YOUR GRANDPARENTS-
WHEN THE POWER GOES OFF AND
THEY THINK THAT THEY HAVE A WAY
TO GET NOTIFICATION THAT THEY
ARE IN DANGER. AND THEY CAN'T
HEAR AT. FOR THEY NEED A HELP
AND THEY GET ON THEIR DEVICE TO
ASK FOR IT AND THEY CAN'T. GET
THROUGH. THAT THE ABSENCES
REALLY. HOW ARE WE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PER. RK
OUR FRIENDS OUR FAMILY OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S REALLY
THE APPROACH THAT WE TOOK WITH
THIS LEGISLATION WASN'T MEANT
TO BE PRESCRIPTIVE THIS IS
EXACTLY HOW. YOU HAVE TO MEET
OUR TASK THE TEST WAS.
PROTECTING LIFE. GIVING PEOPLE
A WAY TO PROTECT THEMSELVES TO
ASK FOR HELP TO RECEIVE OFFERS
OF HELP. THAT THAT'S THE
ESSENCE OF AND I THINK THAT
WHAT YOU HAVE IN THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU. IS TREMENDOUS
COMPROMISE WITH INDUSTRY AND
ALL THE CONVERSATIONS AND
MEETINGS WE HAD WITH THEM.
CONSTRUCT TO TRY TO GET TO A
PLACE WE WENT PRESCRIPTIVE AND
ALL THAT THEY HAD TO DO BUT
JUST AT THE ESSENCE. PROTECT
THAT LIFESAVING LINK. AND A
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL REFER.
WITH THAT JEFF WE ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOUS GLAZER WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO MAIN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ON THE TELEPHONE.
OPERATOR IF YOU OPEN THAT LINE
PLEASE. YEAH YOU HAVE BEEN
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
COREY TONY AND I'M THIS YEAR
CORNER. BUT YOU COUNTY AND
SPEAKING DAY ON BEHALF. OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THAT'S BE.
FORTY ONE. IN RECENT YEARS
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE THE
NUMBER DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
YOU COUNTY WITH SIDE OF THE
TWIN AMP BUT- WHICH CONSUMED
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND ACRES. DISTRICT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES.
RESULTED IN THE TRAGIC DEATH OF
EIGHTY. PEOPLE. JOHN WELL STILL
TO COME FROM THE CATASTROPHIC
YOU CAN REDWOOD AD TAKEN WITH
OF PUBLIC SPEAKING HOW SHUT OFF
NOT YET PEAS. WHICH HAS YOU
KNOW WE'RE IMPLEMENTED REDUCE
POTS THE PART START DURING HIGH
WIND. EACH SHUT OFF BRINGS.
CONCERN ABOUT THE ABILITY OF MY
COMMUNITY COMMUNICATE HEARING A
LOT THE POWER AND GET HELP.
SHOULD THE NEED ARISE. OUR
EXPERIENCE AND YOU COUNTY IS
NOT UNIQUE WE DIDN'T. IN THIS.
HAVE SHOWN THAT THE- PROCESS.
HERE THE PRODUCT NEED BE
IMPROVED FOR ALL RESIDENTS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY
ONE REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
BELT AND IT BUT BACK UP PWER
RULE FOR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES. ARE THAT IT PROVIDED
WITHIN HERE TWO OR THREE HI
FIRED RIGHT DISTRICT. BEFORE
THIRTY ONE WILL APPROVE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND KEEP COMMUNITIES
CONNECTED WITH VITAL SERVICES.
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. YOUR AYE VOTE. ON IT
BEFORE THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UNDERSTAND
ALSO IS A MAIN WITH US IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE MICHAEL
MCLAUGHLIN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE JESUS'S. ON THE TELEPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN AT ONE.
DEADLINE IS CONNECTED COULD YOU
PRESS STAR ZERO AT THIS TIME
YOUR CONNECTED. MISTER
MCLAUGHLIN YOU THERE. THE LINE
IS CONNECTED JUST A TECHNICAL
ISSUE MISTER CHAIR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. FRANK LACHLAN YOUR LINE
IS CONNECTED AND THE COMMITTEE
HAS CALLED ON YOU TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH WE
NEED TO REALLY MEMBERS- MY NAME
IS MIKE MCLAUGHLIN- I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN IT
MY HONOR TO BE TESTIFYING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEF THE COMMISSION IN A
FIRE DISTRICT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK AT THE
BOARD OF SB FOUR THIRTY ONE AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF- PROJECTING
OUR COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE- WELL- I DON'T
HAVE THE PLEASURE BEING
LITERALLY IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY- MY THAT THE HONOR
TESTIFYING. IN MANY VIEW OVER
THE RECENT YEARS- ON A WIDE
ARRAY OF TOPICS INCLUDING YOU
KNOW WILD FIRE- AND RESILIENT
AND COMMUNICATIONS AND- AS
RECENTLY AS LAST YEAR. WAS SOME
OF THE SET AND THE FUNDING. FOR
YOU PRICE EMERGENCY CAN YOU THE
JUST A TRULY REAL
COMMUNICATIONS GENERAL IS
REALLY THE CORE OF THERE REALLY
ARE THAT WE RELY ON IN THE
NUMBER SET TO HELP US TO BE
AFFECTED AND TO BE TO BE ABLE
TO NOT ONLY RECEIVE INFORMATION
AS EMERGING RESPONDERS BUT ALSO
TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND THEN YOU KNOW WITH WITH
THAT YOU KNOW THE
COMMUNICATIONS ASPECT FROM FROM
AN EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION
PERSPECTIVE AND BEING ABLE TO
GET THEM PEARL TIMELY AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION OUT TO THE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY. WELL
AS BEING ABLE TO HAVE SYSTEM UP
AND OPERATING EVEN IN TIMES OF
OUR STATE THE- PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF OR IN DISASTER
SITUATIONS ACRE- THE YOU KNOW
SITUATION DIFFICULT WHEN OUR
COMMUNICATIONS UP THAT THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GO OFF
LINE WITHOUT HAVING BACKUP
POWER AND PLACED AND SO- WITH
THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE HAVE THE
INABILITY TO REACH US IN A TIME
OF NEED AND WE HAD THE
INABILITY OF REACHING THEM AND
THEN PROVIDING COMMUNICATION.
HOW AS FASTER OR WILD FIRES. OR
HE MADE YEARS. WISHING TO MEET.
OUT OF THE- OUT. PEOPLE
31 DEGREES TO PAY BACK UP FOR
CRITICAL COMMUNITY IF. THAT YOU
KNOW A BLACKED SYSTEM IF YOU
WILL WORRY OUT SYSTEM HOWEVER
THE SYSTEM IS DOWN WITH THESE
COMMUNICATIONS JOBS OUT- AS
WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN THE RECENT
PAST- AS RECENTLY AS CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY FIRE LAST YEAR THE
DISPATCH CENTER WAS OFF LINE
FOR- AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME
THAT THE COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK
AND I'LL ONE NETWORK SYSTEM WAS
ULTIMATELY OUTLINED IN THE
RESULT OF A PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT UP. IT WAS AN INADVERTENT
OVERSIGHT BUT IT'S TO
EXPERIENCES LIKE THIS THAT-
BLOOD SENATE MCGUIRE AND THE CO
AUTHORS TO BRING FORWARD THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR BACKUP- VIçT BE ABLE TO
PUT IN PLACE IN REFERRING IT TO
BEST PRACTICES THEY PUTTING
LEGISLATION IN PLACE THAT WOULD
GIVE US A PARAMETER TO KNOW
THAT WHEN POWER GOES WE HAVE.
SEVENTY TWO HOURS OF BACKUP
POWER. LEAVING THE LET XIN OPEN.
TO REFER TO BEST. ALLOW US THE-
OF CLEVER. THE BEST THAT
TECHNOLOGY HAS OFFERED TO GIVE
IMPORTANT TIME TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE PROVIDING. THE BEST MOST
EFFECTIVE MOST EFFICIENT MEANS
OF POWER BACK UP AVAILABLE.
WITH THAT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE FIRE
DESTRUCTION CIRCULATION
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO MOST
NOTABLY THE WESTERN FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING ELEVEN
WESTERN STATES- WIRED YOU TO
VOTE YES ON IMPORTANT ISSUES
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU MISTER MCLAUGHLIN WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. OF PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY. WE'LL START HERE
WITH ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBERS THERE
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED. GO
AHEAD IN THE GALLERY. TESTING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK SMITH ON BEHALF
OF CAL NINO THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY NUMBER ASSOCIATION
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS YOUR
FRIENDLY NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK THANKS VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE CHAMBER
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE AT
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
SEEKING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO TO THE TELEPHONE LINES
MODERATOR IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITNESSES ON
THE TELEPHONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP
WE PRESS ONE ZERO WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE THIRTY THREE
THREE THREE. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CAN STONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND FOR JUST A
SEASON IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY SIX ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE WORD FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR WORLD
POLICY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE FIFTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEGHAN PAPER THAT
WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
EIGHT TO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MISTER CHUCK NOT SHOW
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF. OF THANK
YOU. LINE TWENTY THREE TO THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR OR AFTERNOON THAT
YOU CAN REMEMBER INSTRUCTING
GOLD RIVERS ANY THE WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE SUFFICIENT WE
HAVE A POSITION UP SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTED AND APPRECIATE THE
CENTER. AGREEMENT CONTINUED
DIALOGUE AROUND CERTAIN
AMENDMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MICHAEL RIDE
AGAIN I'LL BE HAPPY THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THE CARD COUNTY
WORK. THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY
NINE FIVE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHICH CHEN MEMBERS BREAK COOK
REPRESENTING THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JOURNAL FOR
THE LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
OKAY WE WILL CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT AND MOVED TO
THE MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE STEVE
CARLSON FROM C. T. I. A ON THE
PHONE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
OPEN AT ONE PLACE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- STEVE CARLTON
WITH EACH YEAH A THE TRADE AT
THE- FOR THE- TELECOM. INDUSTRY
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
WHAT'S BEFORE THIRTY ONE. AT
THE OFFICE OF INDICATED WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING EXTENSIVELY. BUT
SIGNIFICANT OPERATIONAL
CONCERNS REMAIN. WIRELESS
CARRIERS HAVE MADE
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS AND
INVESTMENTS TO MAINTAIN
CRITICAL COMMUNICATION SERVICES
AND EMERGENCY THEN THE PAY FOR
THE WILD HIRED. AND HE HAD HE
HAS A BAND OF ON SIX ONE
FORESEEABLE BREAD AND ACTED TO.
THERE IS NO GREATER. TO
MAINTAIN SERVICE DURING
EMERGENCY THE COMPETITION TO
SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS INCLUDING A
PUBLIC SAFETY PART. LEGISLATION
IS NOT NEEDED FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN AND IT BEYOND THE
JURISDICTIONAL REACH OF THE
STATE. OUR SHARED GOAL IS TO
PAY MAINTAIN SERVICE OUR
COVERAGE NUMBER. DOES NOT
REQUIRE HAVING A MINIMUM AMOUNT
OF BACKUP POWER ON EACH DEL
CITING THOUSANDS OF SMALL CELLS
WHERE IT IS OBJECTIVELY
IMPOSSIBLE. THE INDUSTRY HAS
COMMITTED SEVERAL THIRTY WOMEN
MEN'S BASED ON THE FOLLOWING
FUNDAMENTAL. MANY WIRELESS
LOCATIONS ARE COVERED BY
MULTIPLE SITES WITH THE
OVERLAPPING NETWORK THAT CAN
OFFLOAD INTO YOUR TRAFFIC WHEN
IMPACT. SOME WIRELESS LIKELY
LOCATED IN AREAS WHERE TICKS
GENERATORS HAD TAKE THE INSTALL
WHILE OTHERS REQUIRE MORE
DOUBLE SOLUTIONS BASED UPON
PERMITTING AND OTHER FACTORS.
THAT MAY INCLUDE COMBINATIONS
OF STICK GENERATOR PORTABLE
GENERATORS AND BACKED OUT OF.
SB THIRTY THIRTY FOUR THIRTY
ONE FAILED BY REQUIRING AN
ADDITIONAL ON THAT THE JURY AND
AFFORDABLE FOR PROCESS. LOOKING
AT AND APPROVING OR
DISAPPROVING BACKUP POWER EACH
OF MANY THOUSANDS OF. SUCH A
PROCESS WASN'T BACK REJECTED BY
THE BEAUTY IN ITS RECENT BACK
ABOUT. WHAT WERE LANGUAGE CAN
BE FOUND ON PAGE FOR THE BILL
SECTION THE ONLINE TWENTY FOUR.
WE BELIEVE WE HAVE OFFERED A
WORKABLE SOLUTION BY COMBINING
TEXTURED BEGINI AND REMOVING
THE WAIVER LANGUAGE. BUT THAT
HAS NOT FAR BEEN REJECTED.
MANDATING AN ONEROUS CPUC
WAIVER PROCESS ARE NECESSARILY
DELAYED CARRIER REFERENCE TO
ADDRESS RESILIENCY NEED.
WORKING IN DIRECT CONFLICT THAT
THE AUTHOR STATED INTENT FOR
THE LEGISLATION. ANOTHER
CONCERN IS THE ADDITION OF
BASIC INTERNET BROWSING FOR THE
MINIMUMS MINIMUM SERVICE HI MY
ONE BOY AND TEXT. DO I DURING
AN EXTRA THE FBI THE BEND IN
WHICH BROUGHT WHILE COMMERCIAL
POWER SHUT DOWN. IT MAY NOT BE.
TO MAINTAIN INTERNET SERVICES
WITHOUT. NEGATIVE IMPACTING
PRIORITY ACT AS THE NINE ONE
ONE AND FIRST RESPONDER
SERVICES. THE BILL OF VOICE
SERVICES. RIDLEY THIRTY THREE
READ. AS WELL AS A THE PEACE TO
FIX THAT I. THERE ARE CERTAIN
FASTER WORK WILL A POP TO MAKE
Y. SERVER. INCLUDING EXTEND
COMMERCIAL POWER OUTAGES.
MEMBERS THIS IS THE ONLY POP
POLITICS MAYBE THIS BILL WILL
EVER STATE. OF COURSE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OFFERS THE COMMITTEE AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. TO MAKE SURE THE
POLICY THERE IN PLACE TO
PROVIDE THE BEST ENVIRONMENT TO
MEET THESE CHALLENGES. WE ALL
AGREE ON THE GOAL OF
MAINTAINING WIRELESS SERVICE
DURING DISASTERS. COLLABORATE I
GET UP BY THE OBSTACLES TO THAT
GOAL AND WAYS TO REMOVE THOSE
OBSTACLES. BOTTOM ON WORKABLE
MAY. THANK THANK YOU MR CARSON
I UNDERSTAND WE ALSO HAVE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION
CARROLL AMERICAN TIRE FROM C.
C. T. A MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
OVER THAT LINE PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CAROLINE MCINTYRE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION-
WEEK YOU ARE OPPOSED TO AT THE
FOUR THREE ONE- BEFORE I GET
INTO THE SPECIFICS THAT TO Y.
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO THANK
SENATORS MCGUIRE AND SENATOR
GLACIER. FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
THEY HAVE DONE- IN TRYING TO
ATTRACT AT THE MANY ISSUES THAT
WE BREAK AND WE HAVE MADE.
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS HOWEVER WE
DO HAVE A FEW REMAINING
CONCERNED WITH THE. BILL THAT
IS CURRENTLY IN PRINT. AND AT
THE RELATES THE PER FACILITIES
THAT THE- AT. WILL BE. TO
PROVIDE BACKUP POWER FOR THE
COMMUNICATION NETWORK- WHILE
THE LIST HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROWED. THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
THE AREAS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
STILL SOMEWHAT BROAD IN BUT
HOPE TO WORK WITH THE SENATORS
TO CLARIFY. THE ACTUAL
DEFINITION OF A FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER ANY
WILL PLANET- THE DEFINITION
THAT IS CURRENTLY PROVIDED IS
EXTREMELY PRIDE IN WOULD MAKE
IT DIFFICULT. TO IDENTIFY WHAT
EXACTLY WHAT THE TEL AVIV WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT- IN A- TO
OBJECT BE. WAIVER PROCESS THAT
HAS. BILL FOR I DIRECT THE FACT
THAT MAY IN THE CURE YOUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE BACKUP POWER
INSTEAD THAT WE HAD REQUESTED
SPECIFIC CRITERIA THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BE MAD IN ORDER FOR ACT
TO ENSURE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE BACKUP POWER AND
THERE. THE DIRECTION OR NATIVE
AFTER SITUATION. THOSE WOULD
INCLUDE THE ABILITY TO OBTAIN
PER MATT- FOR BOTH FIGHTING AND
THE AIR QUALITY ISSUES- AND IT
WOULD BE HAPPY BUT HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS SAFE FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES TO GET INTO THE AREA
IN ORDER TO DO REFILLING- WE
WOULD WANT TO RECEIVE A
NOTIFICATION FROM THE ELECTRIC
UTILITY. THAT THEY DO IN FACT
INTEND TO SHUT OFF THE POWER
AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ANY
FACILITY THAT WE ARE BEING
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE BACKUP
POWER TO THE NET FOR. ALSO HAD
THEIR OWN BACK THAT POWER SO
THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY UTILIZE
THE COMMUNICATION SERVICE
WANTED TO PROVIDE TO THEM
UNLESS THEY HAVE THAT THEIR
BACKUP POWER ON SITE IT WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT THERE BUT- I'D ALSO
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT WE HAVE
IN FACT STATISTICALLY REQUESTED
AN EXEMPTION FROM LIABILITY. IN
THAT WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IT
IS FAIR TO PROVIDE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES LIABILITY PROTECTION
BY WAY OF ALLOWING THEM TO SHUT
OFF THE POWER AND THEN NOT
PROVIDE ACT WITH A SIMILAR TYPE
OF LIABILITY PROTECTION.
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO BE OUT
OUT IN THE SAME WEATHER
CONDITIONS TRANSPORTING FUEL
THE MANY GENERATORS IN ORDER TO
KEEP OUR NETWORK UP AND RUNNING
AND THEN LASTLY WE WENT AFTER.
THAT THE LEGISLATION. FOOD WHAT
WELL I CALL AT DAY. BYE WEEK
THAT THE PEOPLE WOULD BE. TO
REPORT TO LIVES OF ON THE RAMP
FROM. OF THE- POWER PROVISIONS
AND- THE WOULD BE. TO HOLD
EVIDENTIARY HEARING BEFORE
CHANGINGTHAT SET UP WELL AND
IMPOSING A NEW SET OF
REQUIREMENTS. WE LIVE HERE TO
BE AB SOME RECOGNITION OF THE
FACT THAT THE INDUSTRY WILL BE
SPENDING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
COMPLY HERE AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS. A SEVEN
PLACE BYE WEEK- ADDITIONAL
FACTOR BEING CONSIDERED BEFORE
THE JOBS. THE CHECK. THE REASON
WE ARE A PART OF THE BILL TODAY
BUT LOOK TO WORKING THE ODD. IN
HOPES BEING A TO ATTRACT PLEASE
REMAIN ISSUE. THANK YOU MISS
MEREKA. LOOKING FOR. THE MAY
OFFICE WHAT DOES TEST WILL MOVE
TO PUT COMMENT. IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. SEEING NANA IS THERE
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
OF ONE OF OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS. SEEING NONE THERE WE
WILL GO TO THE TELEPHONE LINES-
FOR MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THOSE LINES. MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN IN A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
TO ENTER THE QUEUE. WILL GO
FIRST ONLINE. SIXTY FOUR SIX
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NATO
BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS OPPOSE THE MOST
AMENDED CONSISTENT WITH THE TWO
MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER COMMENT IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ALMOST A LINE
TWENTY SIX TWO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD OF TIME. YEAH FIVE THE
TERM SUSAN COME UP WITH- THE
NEW TEAM MOBILE WHICH NOW ALSO
INCLUDES FRANCE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. IF YOU
KNOW FOR THE LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE. COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS. IN THIS TIME
ORDER. THANK YOU FOR. I WE HEAR
TIME AND TIME AGAIN THE FROM
THE CHILD THAT RURAL AREAS
ESPECIALLY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAVE AND I THINK THEY'RE QUITE
DIFFERENT SO I GENERALLY NOT A
SUPPORTER OF ONE SIZE FITS ALL
BUT I THINK WE DO HAVE OUR
ABILITY TO DO WE HAVE TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE. AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHEN WE HAD THE LILAC
HOLES FIRE AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WE HAD PEOPLE WHO DID IT FOR
THEIR POWER WAS OUT THEIR CELL
PHONE- DIDN'T GET ANY RECEPTION
THEY COULDN'T GET LEADING GET
THEIR VALUATION NOTICES SO I
THINK OUR MINIMUM DUTY AND THE
INTENT OF THIS BILLS RIGHT
SAYING THERE'S A MINIMUM LEVEL
INFORMATION WHEN WE DN'T HAVE
PROPER IN THE GROUND ANYMORE
THE PEOPLE HAVE TO HAVE. I DO
THINK IT'S DIFFERENT IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SUBMIT
SOMETHING THE OFFICE CAN
CONTINUE AS YOU CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS BILL- THE
OPPOSITION BY UP A POINT THAT I
THINK IT'S A GOOD WAY. TO FOR
YOUR CLARIFY BECAUSE I THINK
THE CENTER AND I HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION THE WEEKEND- WHAT
HAPPENS IF THERE'S A WILDFIRE
SO DEVASTATING THAT THEY CAN'T-
PROVIDER. CAN NOT GUARANTEED
BACKUP POWER BECAUSE IT BE TOO
DANGEROUS FOR THE FOLKS TO GO
IN. AND DO THAT WHAT IS THAT
LOOK LIKE UNDER YOUR BELT. I
NEVER SEND THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND AGAIN TO
DEPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION-
THIS WEEKEND SO THAT HAPPENS
QUITE A BIT IN FACT OVER THE
LAST THIRTY SIX MONTHS-
EIGHTEEN T. FOR EXAMPLE- HAD
NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET INTO A
ZONE BECAUSE EITHER- THERE IS
STILL ACTIVE FIRE. OR OR- TO
CHANGE YOUR IS ON A ROAD TO BE
ABLE TO GET IN. SO THAT WOULD
BE ACCORDING. BETWEEN STATE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND THAT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDER IN
FACT. THE BILL THAT WE ALL
PASSED LAST YEAR SB. SIX
SEVENTY ONE TO SAY THANK YOU TO
MULTI WHO SUPPORTED THAT
THEY'LL- A REQUIRES NOW
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
BEING CONSTANT CONTACT WHEN
THERE IS AN OUTAGE IN SO THERE
WOULD BE AN ABILITY- SOME
FLEXIBILITY OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE
UNABLE TO GET INTO AN AREA. TO
BE COMMUNITY. BETWEEN COST.
ABOUT IN THAT WOULD UP AND
RUNNING IN CONSEQUENCE CATION
WITH OPERA. CENTER AS WELL AS A
LOCAL EMERGED SERVICES. YEAH SO
WHAT TEMPORE FOR ME. IS THAT.
WHEN THE PROVIDER TRIES TO DO
IT OF COURSE THAT THERE FOR
THAT THEY'RE NOT THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY UNDUE CONSEQUENCES. I
THINK THERE ARE SOME AREAS
WHERE THAT'S GONNA COME
NATURALLY FROM THE MARKET IN
SOME AREAS THAT WON'T. BRING
THAT IS SOMETHING THE OTHER
THING I HAD ABOUT WAS ABOUT THE
WAIVER PROCESS YEAH- YOU KNOW
SOMEONE. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
PUTTING EXTRA LAYERS OF
BUREAUCRACY IN HERE. ON PEOPLE
I THINK WE NEED TO DO SOME
BECAUSE I DO THINK IN SOME
AREAS OF STATE WE DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT LEVEL OF SERVICE- BUT
I WILL WHAT IS THE STATUS OF
THE WAIVER AND YOU KNOW HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE IT'S NOT ON THIS
IS UNNECESSARY AND BURDENSOME.
BUT GETS AT THE CORE OF WHAT
YOU WANT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THEN SHARED SO- THIS WAIVER
PROCESS. THAT WAS BROUGHT UP BY
INDUSTRY IN THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT BEEN GRAPPLING WITH AND
WORKING THROUGH THIS IS
INITIATIVE WE SPENT SOME TIME
WITH THIS WEEKEND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. SO LOOK THE
CHAIR IN OUR OFFICES CREATED A
WAIVER SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO
HELP PROVIDE CERTAINTY TO
INDUSTRY RIGHT BECAUSE
INDUSTRIES COMING BACK TO US
PROVIDE CERTAINTY INDUSTRY
REGARDING THEIR ABILITY TO GET
RELIEF. FOR WAIVERS- AND I'LL
BE HONEST WITH YOU WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY ON THIS WHATEVER
PROCESS. AND IT WAS A PUT INTO
THE BILL TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SOME OF THAT FLEXIBILITY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY WILL JUST
MENTIONED BUT WE'RE GONNA NEED
EIGHTEEN TO WORK WITH INDUSTRY
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. ON THE
MODIFICATION OF THE BILL AND IF
IT'S ALRIGHT- MADAM AS SOMEONE
FOR THE ONE ITEM I SAY. IT IS.
WE JUST HEARD THAT THERE A
REASON THIS BILL. THAT I DID
WANT EVERYONE TO BE. MORE THAN
REASON WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
TYPE OF ISSUES. SO IN FACT WE
HAD A BILL LAST YEAR THAT WE
PARK. WE DIDN'T MOVE FORWARD.
INDUSTRY WAS IN ON MY OFFICE
SEVERAL TIMES INCLUDING A CTIA.
THEY SAID THERE WAS NO REASON
THAT THIS BILL WAS NEEDED. FAST
FORWARD TO THESE MASSIVE
POWERSHOT OFFICE TWO MILLION
PEOPLE TWO MILLION PEOPLE LAND
LINE CABLE AND SO CUSTOMERS HAD
NO ABILITY TO USE YOUR CELL
PHONE. IT COULDN'T GET
EMERGENCY ALERTS THEY COULDN'T
DIAL NINE ONE ONE THEY
COULDN'T- ALSO GET EMERGENCY
TEXT MESSAGES FROM THE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES. SO I'M A
BIG BELIEVER TRUST BUT VERIFY
NOW WHAT WE HAVE VERIFIED IS
THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED BACKUP
POWER IN THE OTHER REALLY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE SHOULD THIS
BILL FROM LAST YEAR WE
ORIGINALLY SENT RAZOR I
ORIGINALLY WERE LOOKING AT.
YEAH YEAH WE FROM INDUSTRY IS
IT'S ABOUT A NETWORK THE NET
RELIABLE. SO RIGHT NOW EIGHTEEN
T. IS BRINGING IN ONE THOUSAND
GENERATORS TO BE ABLE TO
ATTACHED TO SPECIFIC IN
STRATEGIC CELL TOWERS ACROSS
THEIR TERRITORY TO GO TO KEEP
THEIR NETWORK AND A MINIMUM
LEVEL OF A RUNNING. NINE ONE
ONE. EMERGENCY CELL IN TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOME MINIMAL-
INTERNET TO BE ABLE TO CLICK ON
THE LINK TO BE ABLE TO GET TO
YOUR OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES
TEXT ALERTS SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT INDUSTRIES
ALREADY MOVING FOR WITH AS WELL
AND WE WOULD BE HONORED TO BE A
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HIM TO
WORK WITH YOU TO VERY. I'M
STILL. SO WHAT THAT I'VE
EXPRESSED YOU KNOW I DO THINK
WE NEED TO MAKE THIS ABOUT
LEVEL OF SERVICE GET OUT OF A
BACK POWER GENERATION
MICROMANAGING WHERE THEY PUT
STUFF CORRECT- I DO NEED THINK
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
WHEN IT'S NOT POSSIBLE AND NOT
MAKING THEM ON THE HOPE FOR
SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN'T
POSSIBLY DO- AND SO I THINK YOU
ARE ON THE RIGHT PATH SO I'M
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A
COURTESY I TODAY AND THE FOR
THOSE MEMBERS OF THE COME TO
THE FORE. WE CONTINUE THE-
WE'VE BEEN HAVING. NUMEROUS
MEETINGS WITH. CABLE LAN LINE
AS WELL AS- SO PROVIDERS AND
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT IT'S THE RIGHT TING TO
DO. AND WE NEED TO BE A TO GET
THIS RIGHT FOR THE SAFETY OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU
NEXT I HAVE A MISTER PATTERSON
FOLLOWED BY MISS KAMLAGER
FOLLOWED BY MR LOW. YEAH THANK
YOU BOB. WELL FIRST OF ALL. I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT- I WANT
TO MAKE THAT. CLEAR NUMBER ONE
BUT NUMBER TWO I ALSO THINK
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A LITTLE
TOO- LESS OF I THINK A
WILLINGNESS TO REALLY ENGAGE
WITH THE OPPOSITION I KNOW YOU
SAID THE END OF THE TABLE I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS A LONG TIME. BUT THERE ARE
CONSIDERABLE HOLES IN THIS THAT
YOU HAVE HEARD OTHER. MEMBERS
COMMENT ABOUT HERE THE CONCERN
I HAVE IS THAT THE BEST OF
INTENTIONS IN THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. ACTUALLY CAN AND
I'VE BEEN HERE SIX YEARS CAM-
DEVELOP UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
AND I THINK THAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM THE PROVIDERS IN THOSE
AFFECTED BY THIS THAT NUMBER
ONE THEY ARE PERFECTLY WILLING
AND ARE PRESENTLY DOING WHAT
THEY CAN. TO GET ALL OF THIS
BACK UP DONE IN SUCH A WAY THAT
ACTUALLY CREATES THE KINDS OF
OUTCOMES YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
THEIR CONCERN HAS TO DO WITH
THE FLEXIBILITY AND THE OF. THE
LIKELIHOOD. OUR THAT WHAT YOU
ARE PRESCRIBING IS ACTUALLY
SOMETHING THAT IN THE FIELD
WILL ACTUALLY HELP AND SO I'M
GOING TO BE A NO VOTE NOW YOU
MENTIONED A VERIFIED THEN TRUST.
TRUST BUT VERIFY. I'M GOING TO
VERIFY VERIFY THEN TRUST YOU
HAVE SAID YOU WILL WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION THAT IS CORRECT
ABOUT OPPOSITION WORK WILL
CONTINUE TO GO FORWARD THIS IS
THAT CORRECT- YEAH I MEAN WE
YES WE WE'VE MET WITH THEM I
MEAN A DOZEN TIMES MAYBE MORE
STASSEN IT WITH THEM. HI I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
COMMITMENT IS NOT MERELY TO
SIMPLY. GO THROUGH THE MOTIONS
BUT TO ACTUALLY TAKE A GOOD
HARD LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING FOR. I WANT TO.
REITERATE I THINK SOME OF THE
CONCERNS HERE WITH RESPECT TO
THE WAIVERS BUT ALSO ONE IN A
IN A IN A MUCH BROADER SENSE
THE PC HAS A NEW PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT BADGER. I HAPPEN TO
BE A FAN OF HERS I AM VICE
CHAIR OF UTILITY AND ENERGY AND
THAT COMES AS MAYBE SOME
SURPRISE YOU SEE HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT IN TIMES PAST. I WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THE PC HAS
HAS MADE. ARE A VERY CLEAR AND
IN. MY JUDGMENT A COMPREHENSIVE.
RULING ON THIS AND- I'M AT A
LOSS TO UNDERSTAND WHY THAT
RULING. AND THE- EXPECTATIONS
OF IT FROM THE REGULATORY
AGENCY. OUR IS NOT SATISFACTORY
WHY THE OTHER LAYER OF A P. YOU
SEE INVOLVEMENT IN A IN A IN A
WAY FOR WHY A PRO SCRIPT GIVE
EFFORT TO BASICALLY SAY YOU'RE
GONNA DO YOU GOT TO DO ALL OF
THESE BACK UPS. WHETHER OR NOT
YOU CAN ACTUALLY GET. TO THEM
WHETHER THEY'RE SAFE OR WHETHER
THEY EVEN WORK. AM I CAN IS
THAT THE EFFORT TO DO THAT
TECHNOLOGY IN THIS BILL. MATT
IS A HUGE ALLY IN THIS. THE
VERY ONES WHO HAVE TO DO IT. SO
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THEIR CONCERNS AND
ALSO TO RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
WHEN THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
TASKED WITH THIS. HEY AT THAT
OF THERE'S NO REASON FOR THE
BILL. UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING IS THEIR
COMMITMENT IS ONGOING RIGHT NOW
TO GET THIS DONE WHAT THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT THE
BILL ACTUALLY GETS IN THE WAY
OF A CLEAR AND A DIRECT THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF THE KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE BACK UPS. WE
LIKE TO THINK THAT WE CAN WAIVE
SOME KIND OF A MAGIC WAND AND
PUT IT DOWN ON A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THE REALITY IS
THAT LEGISLATION HAS TO COMPORT
WITH PHYSICS. AND HAS TO
COMPORT WITH GEOGRAPHY AND
HASTERT COMPORT WITH SAFETY AND
WHAT CAN BE DONE. HI I'M GOING
TO BE A NO VOTE I WISH THAT. I
COULD COME TO THE FLOOR WHEN
IT. AND IF IT GETS THERE. OUGHT
TO BE AN AYE VOTE BUT IN ORDER
FOR. ME TO BE COMFORTABLE I
THINK OTHERS. I'M ASKING THAT
YOU PAY ATTENTION IN IT AGAIN-
AND- GO BACK TO THOSE WHO HAVE
TO DO THIS- AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY ARE- TRYING VERY VERY HARD
TO. ACHIEVE IT- AND THEY WANT
TO HELP AND I WANT TO GET IT
DONE. BUT THEIR CONCERNS ARE
REAL. AND NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
NOT FOR THE SAKE OF. THE
POLITICS OF THIS FOR THE SAKE
OF THE REALITY. OF ACTUALLY
DOING IT APPRECIATE THAT AT THE
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RESEARCH HERE WITH A VERY TO
RESPOND. YEAH SURE BUT- JUST.
KNOWING THAT IT'S TWELVE FORTY
FIVE WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
SESSION IN HERE ONE GO AHEAD
GOT IT I'LL BE VERY QUICK- I
TOO USED TO BELIEVE THAT.
INDUSTRY WAS GOING TO. DO THIS
AND MAKE THESE IMPROVEMENTS BY
THEMSELVES. IN IN. THERE IN OUR
OFFICE LAST YEAR SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO GET IT DONE. WE
ALREADY HAVE A- THERE'S ENOUGH
GENERATORS IN STATE. AND THEN
WE HAD TWO MILLION FOLKS LOSE
THEIR ABILITY TO USE THEIR
CELLPHONE OR LANDLINE INDOOR
THEIR CABLE PHONE. THEY HAD TO
BRING IN OVER TWO HUNDRED
GENERATORS FROM ARIZONA TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP THEIR NETWORK
RUNNING AFTER THEIR NETWORK
HAD. GONE BLACK UP WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ISSUES OF
LISTENING TO THE INDUSTRY I'D
LIKE TO BETTER TALK ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE TAKEN
NUMBER ONE WE HAVE GONE FROM A
TOWER BY TOWER. TO A BASIC
LEVEL OF SERVICE THAT WAS
LISTENING TO INDUSTRY NUMBER
TWO ONE THE ISSUE OF A BACKUP
AT POWER REQUIREMENTS COMPLETE
FLEXIBILITY INDUSTRY ON HOW
THEY MAINTAIN THEIR NETWORKS
THEY TELL THE DO YOU SEE THE
STATE ON WHICH TOWERS ARE
CRITICAL TO BE TO KEEP THEIR
NETWORKS UP AND RUNNING. AND
THEN THEY ARE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THE GENERATOR INTO THAT
SPECIFIC SITE I THE ISSUE WHEN
IT COMES TO- LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS JUST BEING VERY
CANDID THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
AGREE UPON IT IS NOT BEEN IN
ANY OTHER BILL SIMILAR TO THIS.
AND THEN FINALLY AND I KNOW
THEY'RE RUNNING A TIME IN
REGARDS TO THE ISSUE OF PERMITS
THIS BILL ALLOWS THIS IF YOU
SEE THE BABY OR DELAYED THERE
BECAUSE- SHOULD THERE BE
HENDRIX LET PERMITS. ONE AROUND
FOLKS WILL BE RE MY US IN THE
QUIRK ALL HAS A PERMIT X. THE
IS MOVING FORWARD PASSAGE HERE
HOUSE IT'S JUST PASS AT A
GOVERNMENT'S FIND IN THE SENATE
WITH BY. OR THAT'S GONNA THEM
IS. AND OVER TIME. AT THE
AUTHOR I'M JUST GONNA THIS UP
ON THE SIDE OF COULD TO I I'VE
BEEN TOLD I HAVE WE HAVE TO AND
IT'S OF THE GO TO SESSION NO
REASON PLEASE WITH KAMLAGER
FOLLOW MY MISSED LOW AND I THE
AUTHOR THE LITTLE SORT. GREAT
AND I WILL MAKE THAT. THANK YOU.
FOR YES. AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WITH OUR- I HAVE TO REQUEST. SO
AS A RELATES TO THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR BACK. MOST CELL TOWERS
ALREADY HAVE SOME KIND OF
EITHER A BACKUP GENERATOR OR
BATTERIES AND SO IS THIS-
REQUIREMENT ON TOP OF THAT IN
WINDOWS THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR.
BACKUP PERIOD START DOES IT
START AFTER THE UTILITY OF SHUT
OFF OR DOES IT START AFTER THE
CELL TOWER HAS BECOME AN
OPERATIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
THERE- THERE ARE A LOT OF CELL
TOWERS SAID HAVE ANYWHERE
BETWEEN EIGHT AND TWELVE HOUR-
GENERATOR SOME HAVE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR GENERATORS IT DEPENDS ON
THE SITE. TWO FOR. TWO REASONS
NUMBER ONE THE SIZE IN HOW MUCH
SIZE YOU CAN THERE IS HOW ROOM
IS AROUND CELL TOWER. NUMBER
ONE IN THE NO TWO SUMMER OLDER
SOME ARE NEWER AND SOME OF THE
NEWER HAVE LONGER GENERATORS-
AS FAR AS TIME WHEN IT THIS
WOULD KICKING AT TIME OF THE
POWER SHUT OFF. SEVENTY TWO
HOURS BUT- THAT THIS IS THIS
BILL WILL MEAN LARGER
GENERATORS WOULD NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BE BROUGHT IN. TO THAT
MOST OF THE SITES AGAIN
EIGHTEEN T. I'M AMUSING ROUGH
NUMBERS THEY'RE ALREADY
BRINGING IN- I THOUSAND LARGE
GENERATORS FOR CRITICAL CELL
SITES WITH IN THEIR IN THEIR
TERRITORY TO BE A TO KEEP. A
MINIMUM LEVEL OF THE NETWORK
RUNNING ALREADY- AND NOW THIS
WOULD BE REQUIREMENTS BUT
THROUGHOUT I DON'T KNOW IT
SOME. CENTER ANYTHING YOU WANT
TO ADD TO THAT. SO THEN THE
SECOND QUICK CONCERNS THAT CP.
IS STILL CONSIDERING WIRELESS
RESILIENCY RULES AND HAS I
THINK JUST ASK FOR SOME
COMMENTS- SO WHAT HAPPENS IF
THIS LEGISLATION IS OUT OF SYNC
WITH THOSE PURPLE SEVENTY
COMPLETELY TRANSPARENT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING WITH THE C. P. C.
ON THIS BILL AS WELL- AND
BELIEVE IT THIS GOT. UPON ENTRY.
THANK YOU ONE RIGHT REMIND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I FEEL
HORRIBLE ABOUT RUSHING THIS
BOOK FOR NO OTHER REASON THAN
SESSION IS STARTING SO I REALLY
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT. MR LOW. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF AN
ADJUSTER GIVE THE VERY BRIEF
BUT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
AUTHORS ASSEMBLY HAD
LEGISLATION WITH RESPECT TO. A
NOTIFICATION SO THEY SAY A C.
SIGNIFICANT PARITY ON THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT BUT MY
QUESTION WAS WITH RESPECT OR
COMMENT WITH RESPECT TO THE
WIRELINE. RESILIENCY PROCESS
AND THAT IS C. P. YOU SEE I DO
HAVE RESERVATIONS SIMILAR TO.
I'VE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT FOR
THE CPC SO I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME INCONSISTENCY WITHOUT OF
WHATEVER THE REX MIGHT COME
ABOUT WITHOUT OF LEGISLATION
BUT PERHAPS YOU CAN JUST
ADDRESS THAT YOU'RE CLOSE. AS
WELL. THANK YOU. LET'S
RODRIGUEZ PLEASE YES THANK JUST
KEEP IT REALLY SHORT I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION FOR.
AS YOU KNOW MY BACKGROUND WORK
WITH THE MS PUBLIC SAFETY FOLKS
FOR MANY YEARS COMMUNICATION IS
KEY TO A RESPOND TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO FOLKS OUT CITY
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT- THE
OPPOSITION WAS TALKING ABOUT
ALL I DO IS I CAN URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING OPPOSITION
COME TO A BETTER PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THAT. FOR ONE ARE FOR
SPONSORS HAVE WITHIN THIS THIRD
TO DO THEIR JOB TO PROTECT THE
FOLKS HERE CALIFORNIA. ALSO
ONCE AGAIN JUST CONTINUE- TO
WORK WITH THEM AND- WE'LL SEE
OF THE BILL WASN'T OUT THANKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MET MR HOLDEN PLEASE.
I'M NOT A QUESTION BUT JUST
SORT OF A RECOGNITION OF THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE RAISED- I'M
GOING TO BE A COURTESY
YESTERDAY- I STILL NEED TO KIND
OF WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE
THINKING AROUND THE CPUC AND
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
IN THAT REGARD BUT I DO APPLAUD
THE SENATORS EFFORT TO TRY TO
BE- AGGRESSIVE IN PROACTIVE
AROUND AN ISSUE THAT HAS
CREATED A GREAT DEAL OF
CONSTERNATION. FRUSTRATION AND
ANGER OUR AND CERTAINLY THE PGA
ANY A TERRITORIES AND OF FROM
LAST YEAR AND SO I RECOGNIZE
THAT AND- CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO REVIEW APPARENTLY READY
WELL. AT HI IF THERE'S ANYTHING
I CAN ALONG THE WAY AND HOW TO
DO SO. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT'S ABOUT. GET AT THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THE PROGRESS WE'VE
MADE ON THE BILL FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD ON A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE JUST TO EXTEND
THEIR ON GOING CONCERN JUST ONE
OR TWO TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE
BUT YOU READY STARTED TO TRY TO
STRENGTHEN AND IMPROVE THE BILL
IF YOU GO FORWARD THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I WILL BE VERY BRIEF
JUST THE THANK- THE COMMITTEE
FOR ITS DELIBERATE. ATTENTION
TO THIS BILL IN ITS ROBUST
CONVERSATION- TO THE OPPOSITION
WHO IS ENGAGED. EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY. NOT GONNA BE THE- BUT
SIR. HAS SEEN SICK. MOVE
TOWARDS. AND TôI AND FOR THE
AUTHORS WHO REALLY. DUG INTO
THE WEEDS. AND LEFT NO STONE
UNTURNED. TO TRY TO GET TO THAT
SPOT. TO MAKE THIS BILL
SUCCESS- NUMBER HANDY BACK OVER
AND HOPE THAT THAT WAS A
CLOSING. THANK YOU ALL THIS SAY
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK AS
WE ALWAYS HAVE BEEN- WITH THE
OPPOSITION IN FACT A CHAIR THAT
WAS IN A MEETING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AND US TO BE ABLE
TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE
FINAL ITEMS ARE TO BE A TO GET
TO MISTER LOWEST POINT- WE'RE
GOING TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
CONSISTENCY IN REGARDS TO WHAT
THAT. FUTURE FINAL RULING WILL
BE FROM THE PC AS WELL TO SPILL
IN CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING
IT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND YOU HAVE OUR
WORD THAT WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO DO WHAT WE'VE ALWAYS DONE AT
SINCERELY ENGAGE. WITH THE
OPPOSITION. WITH MANY DECADES
AGO THE LEGISLATURE IN THEIR
WISDOM. WHEN OUR PHONE LINES
WERE ROTARY DIAL DECIDED THERE
SHOULD BE A LIFE LINE RATES.
VERY PROGRESSIVE THERE WAS ALSO
ABOUT HEALTH AND SAFETY. AND I
WOULD SAY IN REGARD TO THE
COMMENT SO WE'VE HEARD TODAY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THIS
LEGISLATION IS. NO DIFFERENT. A
BASELINE FUNDAMENTAL BASELINE
OF LIFE AND SAFETY A LIFELINE.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
TRIED TO DO IN THIS BILL WERE.
CERTAINLY OPEN TO OTHER. WAYS
IN WHICH WE CAN DO IT. AND WE
WANT TO DO IT IN A FAIR WAY AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE
FOR YOU TRY TO CREATE A MINIMUM
LEVEL. IF THERE'S ACTIONS BY
THE PC AND OTHERS TO RAISE IT
HIGHER. THAT'S FINE BUT LET'S
AT LEAST THAT THE GROUND. FLOOR
FOR WHAT WE THINK IT'S A
REASONABLE LEVEL OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY BUT THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK AND I ABOUT. WE NEED A
FIRST AND SECOND. HOWEVER FOR
SOME KAMLAGER. AND SECOND FOR
MISTER RODRIGUEZ. PLEASE CALL
IN THE PAST. MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO.
HI SANTIAGO ALL OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NINE GOVERNOR
BOERNER HORVATH NAY BONTA. WHAT
DAVID CHIU DAVID CHIU ARE FLORA.
BORN NOT HOLDING I WANT TO GET.
IN ORDER FOR YEAH HOLDEN. ALL
ARE KAMLAGER KAMLAGER ADD LOW.
LOW PATTERSON. PATTERSON NAY
QUIRK SILVA. BUT STILL THE NOT
VOTING RODRIGUEZ BUT WE GET OUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NINETY
THROUGH THE BILL THAT. THE BILL
PROCEEDS. AND WE HAVE A BILL ON
CALL AND THAT WOULD BE SB
ELEVEN THIRTY. PROCEED PLEASE.
BONTA HEART BONTA DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU ALL THAT WATER
GARCIA IN ORDER TO ADD. NINETY
THREE TO BUILD OUT. NINETY BILL
MOVES. EVERY. THIS CONCLUDES
THE COMMITTEE. ALL.